Tony we have a quote from you and it is
writing is about putting life on the
page it's about finding the amazing and
the mediocrity and the Beautiful in the
sewers
it's important to get it on the page
and be a writer
can we talk about that quote sure that
sounds great I don't know when I said
that okay it sounds good yeah sure
um
I guess probably at the time when I was
when I said that I was probably thinking
of just uh
getting life's messiness and the beauty
on uh on the page
um or on the screen if we can
um
because
I mean that's what I try to go that's
what I try to go for when I'm writing is
what's the heartache and then you know
what devastates me and then I'm like
Okay now what's the levity uh what's the
um
where
where can where can I find the the
emotional breath in it where because
just as I continue to write and live I
just find out oh wait everything is kind
of suffering and struggle but there's a
lot of joy in it and if if I'm
struggling then there's joy so let's
it's I guess for putting it on the page
we condense it into a tincture of um
our struggles and our Joys because
when it's you know whether we're writing
a novel or a screenplay the
um
it's it's so much more boring than our
real life our real life is very boring
and the screenplay is a condensed
version of it so if we can just condense
those
the Beauty and the awfulness of just
being a human and then just kind of move
it around and
a lovely tragedy sad comedy way I think
that's maybe that's what I was trying to
get at I'm not sure
when you work with your students do you
notice they tend to lean one side or the
other in terms of some are more about
the mediocrity and the messiness and the
others are more about the beauty and you
have to find a middle ground they most
students have a hard time just getting
into conflict
I'm always more more so it's it's uh
especially beginning students or
students in the second quarter where
it's like
they're like this is cool but where's
this conflict and open and and it's
about finding you know when the writing
dialogue and I and I you know I see what
they're doing with their characters I'm
like oh this is sexy you know I'm
noticing something about this
character's relationship to the mother
what do you do you know the
three-dimensional
character of the mother that she's
referring to because if you know that
then you'll know more about that
character and you don't need to say all
of it but you need to know it and that
will inform your
your dialogue it'll inform how your
character presents themselves in the
room it'll inform how the character
interacts with other characters so
um
so a lot of it is yeah push more
conflict and at the same time
just right when you just write and and
get and you get the first uh you get the
first layer down then you then it's
funny to start noticing things
where you're just like oh wait a second
that character might have a a
stepbrother who does blank and you don't
even need to
add that to the screenplay or to the
story but having that little bit of
backstory brings in another dimension of
the character and it's sometimes um
when it gets to a director when he gets
to an actor they're feeling something
deeper because you put something deeper
in there so they can dig into something
deeper and I feel like that's when the
beauty happens and we don't tell each
other What the deeper was we let
everyone do their own deeper and then um
then they then yeah that's
where uh so my student yeah as students
as students grow I think a lot of it is
just putting the time into writing and
the rewriting and put and just and then
they kind of start seeing the character
laid out and then when the characters
laid out oh wait a second it's funny how
I put that dialogue in I didn't even
notice at the time but they may have a
problem with blank and explore that
blank and then come back and go does
this work in here no but I know that
this person has a problem with that and
kind of layer it in later in the story
interesting so let's suppose I'm going
to write something about a CEO and this
CEO is very sort of he has almost like a
dictatorship relationship with his
employees but what we don't know is his
father used to to run the company but we
don't know that as as the viewer as the
reader and his father was even more of
sort of a he had like a general that you
know ruled with an iron fist so if we
knew that as a writer but we don't have
to tell people it's kind of in our back
pocket then then it might help with how
our main character interacts we know
that he has this history with his father
yeah and we can we can put subtle bread
crumbs in there to write it that way and
when it gets to a director they may see
it these I I've noticed
um that they'll add their relationships
and their past to the stories so it
might not even be a father it could be
an old boss they used to work with and
then so they put a dynamic to that and
then when it gets to the actor the
actors like okay how am I interpreting
this on my own what what does this mean
to me and so they'll see how this
character is acting if they're acting
like um like they're a dictator uh
they'll also know that in their mind
that that uh that character believes
that they're doing the best they can for
Humanity it's like they're the hero of
Their Own Story even if they're awful
people but so it's like finding that
balance of where is the humanity because
that humanity is coming from somewhere
so it could come from abuse of a father
it could come from so many different
other things it could come from where
they grew up how they grew up and they
feel like what they're doing is right to
bring in the whole uh to bring in
whatever group they're trying to bring
in and that's when um that's when the
beauty happens and that's when we don't
see we we know it as screenwriters but
then we don't say it and then it's fun
to see a director go oh and then they
just kind of see them start to bring
their own stuff in they see the actor
bring their own stuff in and just don't
ask any questions just let them do their
thing that's that's when the Great
directors and the great actors are just
like they pull it together so we got to
do our part on the page and then that it
makes it it's uh it gives them a huge
opening to explore in themselves
whatever part of the camera they're on
interesting right so so having so
knowing when to get out of the way of
your own work and allow the the actor
and the directors to kind of bring their
own pieces to it oh totally yeah and and
especially for uh for Jesus jerk I was a
part of the whole process when I was on
set every day and um and I just I was
fortunate I've taken acting classes and
I took classes on directing you know
like 20 years ago and then when and then
when all when all that came together
it's like everything came together of oh
okay I kind of knew what to do and what
not to do when I got on set and it was
just like let it breathe and then when
uh when I felt like there needed to be
an adjustment I would never talk to an
actor I would talk to the I would just
pull the director aside really quick and
go hey and it had to be a it had to be a
major thing and I would just like oh
this this and this and they'd be like
okay you turn around he goes you know
what let's try something else and he
would be taking my note but it wouldn't
be uh it's it's um
there's a beauty in finesse I guess to
uh to letting people do their jobs and
you want to let people do their jobs
because they are good at their jobs you
know
so with your students when it's a new
writer and and you you want to bring out
more in them maybe maybe they're afraid
of putting in Conflict maybe they've
been told oh let's only say nice things
we don't want to we don't want to be you
know a bad person or whatever how do you
how do you coax them to not not do
something overly salacious where
anyone's harmed but let's bring some
realism to it
I think that I think the conflict's
already there
sometimes I call it the agreeables so if
there's a if they send me two pages of a
scene and it's agreeable
um that those characters can't agree
with the outcome but they can't agree to
what the outcome is how to get to the
outcome
so they they their point of view needs
to be very um
needs to be almost like
uh what would you say maniacal because
their point of view is right on the page
to get to that outcome and they both
want to get to the same outcome but
um to get there there's got to be
friction amongst themselves so if if
they're agreeable Then I then that's
when I'm just like what's your
character's point of view on this
exactly why do they want to get there
what's behind theirs okay what's behind
them what um if you know if they're
sisters What conflict do they have uh
with uh being siblings if you know if
they're just best friends What conflict
do they have if they're cops in a buddy
movie great they're buddies but these
buddies are going to be at odds with
each other on how to get to where they
both want to go
how do you search for those beautiful
moments in the midst of tragedy
I think I find the tragedy first I think
that tragedy is what guts me and then um
and then I try to find meaning in the
tragedy meaning and my tragedies
um
and it's hard to find meaning in the
tragedy I've uh I've
I mean since Confessions of a Teenage
Jesus jerk I've written two other books
where I went even deeper into tragedies
and one I checked myself into a
outpatient hospital program because I
was suicidal so um
the
I've had to learn
to pick my tragedies and then also
um and also give them time I think and
that's I wasn't giving my tragedies
enough time but
I the the beauty of tragedy is
we're we all have tragedies we all it's
we connect on it and I think um I think
as humans we we connect more
on not just the tragedy but how we got
out of the tragedy like even in film
even in film it's like you put your
character into conflict then we want to
know how are they going to get out of
the conflict how are they getting out of
that little tragedy moment in scene and
then that's what shows character
building and I feel like we're character
building around each other when we do
have tragedies in our lives when we can
we find our ways to pull out of it and
then survive and then go wait a second
okay how does this work for me
in
um you know in being with other people
and then other people it's it's you know
it's just um the beauty of oh yeah I've
been through that you just you hear
someone who goes oh yeah now I've been
through that I get it that's all you
need and you're like ah and there's just
instant camaraderie with
tragedy which is sad I don't know why we
need tragedy and we all just can't be uh
joyful Buddhas but for some odd reason
tragedy and suffering I think is in the
theme of our lives and our existence so
when we put it on the page
um and we get to see our protagonist get
into the tragedy get into the conflict
whatever the conflict is the conflict
could be the protagonist wants to ask
the woman of his dreams out on a date
you know or it could be the protagonist
is being riddled by bullets and they're
trying to die when they're in the
trenches and as far as the film is
concerned and the conflict's concerned
the stakes are the same and as far as
what the characters
um internal tragedy is happening I I
like to even um even when I have
students who are writing romantic
comedies and they apologize for it I'm
sorry I'm like don't apologize and I was
like watch mob movies watch mob movies
and and as you look at the Beats of the
conflict of the mob movies it's very
simple because there's a lot of
hierarchy involved and then bring it
over to your romantic comedy and you can
add those beats in and keep those Stakes
just as high as the mob film and but
it's but it'll be under the guise of a
you know romantic comedy and the
greatest you know the the fun comedy
Vibe a lot of it comes from a tragedy or
a tragic place and that's when it's even
more funny yeah so that's great do you
have certain movies you recommend one
romantic comedy versus one mob movie oh
that would be uh yeah I wish I had those
um I while I watched that TV series
Gamora recently uh the Italian I think
is the Italian one um but as for mob
movies you know I'll tell them to watch
I mean I I you know I spoke ahead I
don't have I'm not a I don't have a good
uh I don't have a good knowledge of
romantic comedies or mob movies but
um one one movie I bring up a lot in
class and it drives some people nuts is
swingers
um I think that was 1996. John Favreau
and Vince Vaughn and
their group of friends and you know John
favreau's character his name's Mike and
he's the protagonist and he's trying to
get over his girlfriend that he's trying
to get over heartbreak he's trying to
make it in LA but mainly he's trying to
get over heartbreak and everyone in the
movie just wants to help him get over
heartbreak but if you really watch the
movie and you watch the dialogue that's
happening they are fighting the whole
time it's almost like they're about to
come to blows with their dialogue but
they all want the same thing they just
want Mikey to feel better Mikey just get
over your girl your ex-girlfriend but
they're they're it's a constant push and
pull and it's funny and it's sad and so
when this when their BR when the point
of view of each character is bringing in
that high of stakes to the same goal
that's when you know it's I mean if it's
it's a it's a tragedy
to watch the movie the whole movie's a
tragedy but it's hilarious because
everyone's the the angle they're
fighting at is just funny sure sure I
didn't think there are some in um
Moonlight and Mystic Pizza there's a lot
of dialogue that's very similar to that
too where there's it might be loving but
they're yelling and and sort of it is
like rapid fire with the dialogue yeah
that's and that's when it's beautiful
and that's when we connect because you
know it's like we want we want the
character to win you know it's like how
is the character going to win how are
they going to get there and then we
almost you know when when they're when
there's heavy conflict on the screen
it's almost like they start to go into a
situation like no don't go there okay if
you go there you better do blank blank
and blank and of course they're not
going to do that because we want to keep
the movie going another five minutes so
it can't be resolved yet they need to
get more uh sand in their eyeballs
before they get to the next scene so why
do you think your student s feel they
have to apologize or some of them feel
they have to apologize for wanting to
write romantic comedies I don't know you
know it's
I think people apologize for genre
sometimes and and I'm just like don't
apologize it's uh
every story means something
no matter what you're doing and it's and
it's what you love you know just it was
write the movies that write a movie that
you love that is why do we go to see
movies and you and whereas movie Just
Hits you in the heart and you're like oh
my God that movie is great even if it's
pretty woman but if that's what gets you
if that's what stirs your soul there's a
reason for it write that right don't
write that movie but write write the um
write the general idea and the general
theme of that movie right uh you know
write the Meg Ryan Tom Hanks movie it's
it's all just it's I think maybe there's
a um there's a pressure for like oh is
it Oscar worthy oh with this with this
would Meryl Streep be cast in this and
it's just like no right right your truth
right what's important to you and that's
going to make the best movie that you
can make no you know never write towards
something that you just feel like is a
good idea you know that's uh that
everyone's on and on about
remember the movie foxes
I don't oh okay it has Scott Baio Jody
Foster Sally Kellerman and is uh from
The Runaways Sherry Curie oh my god oh
okay so and it's it's a and it's the one
of these movies where it just doesn't
leave you and so it's one of these
things where you would say it and people
go oh you like that movie but there
shouldn't be anything wrong with liking
a movie Yes it calls to you I totally
agree and I don't like it when people uh
dirt on other people for liking
something right that just irks me to no
end and I think that doesn't lead to
more conversation that leads to a stop
and so I just you know if it doesn't
matter what people like it's fun it's
it's you know it's like you know when I
come from the music a College radio
music DJ which was the snottiest the
snottiest in the 1990s and I was that
jerk and I could so and it started to
realize wait just because someone
doesn't know Sonic Youth or the
Acoustics doesn't mean that they're
inferior humans
um you know or maybe they don't like a
certain thing like even the you know
it's if they don't like something it's
fun to find out why that's the that's
the oh why don't you like that or why do
you like that well you know I I found a
I found a uh Backstreet Boys song for a
project I was working on and I'm like
this is perfect and I you know I know
everyone's there's gonna be a lot of
people that are going why is Tony
putting a Backstreet Boys song in there
but um
but it's just like
it's just perfect and if someone wants
to go see the Backstreet Boys
just let them let them enjoy their
experience I don't like it when people
try to crush people's experiences if
they want to see Meg Ryan and Tom Hanks
possibly get together
great why why do you like that movie
that's that's we should be passionate
about it because every life's hard
enough as it is so you know
um taking a crap on people's taste is
kind of the last thing we need to do
let's try to find out why they like a
certain thing that's where the fun
stories are as far as I'm concerned yeah
I agree I agree I think people should
whether it's music or books or or film
yeah you should be entitled to if we
want to watch a real cheesy movie and
and enjoy it and and or even have it
playing in the background all the time
there's something that calls to us I use
Ocean's 11 a lot in my uh this is the
solderberg uh I always say his name
wrong I hope I said it right that time
uh his his remake
um but that movie's gorgeous as far as a
heist movie and all the elements of
Storytelling and I actually I'll watch
it for fun sometimes and people kind of
are just like you know it's like oh yeah
well that top 40 movie what are you
talking about and I'm like no there's
actually there's a lot of great scenes
in there that I'll bring to class and
show the Dynamics of and just the
dialogue and the dialogue is tight and
those actors are all top-notch actors
yeah some of them are superstars that's
fine but they are great at what they do
and there's a reason why
most of them are superstars it's because
they've worked really hard to get there
how do you write evil easily enough
unfortunately I think we got a lot of
evil in all of us so it's okay to just
dive into the part of us that's dark
um if
I'm uh you know it's I think writing
evil is
to write evil you have to almost pretend
like no one's going to read it because
you don't want you don't want to anyone
to think you're evil oh my God I would
never be that evil well there's just a
beauty to knowing we all have an evil
inside of us and we can go there we just
choose not to sure so
there's there's just a beauty of just
really letting it go on the page and not
um
and and some people will read it and be
like oh you know I mean I you know I
can't write serial killers like that
narrative just that scares me I don't
like
you know I can never watch a serial
killer film those things just don't make
sense to me but you know we we can find
we can embrace the um our Tendencies
because because we all have bad in us
it's you know and we're not uh
we're not politicians well politicians
have more bad than people than normal
but um but we're not trying I don't
think we need to present ourselves
as beautiful flowers where we we're all
a little corrupt
um and
especially in the film industry you see
a lot more corruption under the guise of
like oh this is virtue and you get
behind the curtain a little bit and
you're like ooh so uh it's
it's kind of easy to write evil it's
it's almost easier to write evil than it
is to write uh you know Evil's
interesting it is yeah and do you think
it's more interesting to write a
virtuous character who secretly has evil
or an evil character that you know you
see it and you go okay this is
definitely evil and then you're seeing
sort of what that person's life is like
Are we more intrigued by what's not
shown and what we're discovering as the
audience
as well I'll first answer that as the
writer so what I try to do is when I
find I go back into my life and I go you
know what I hate that I hate that person
I hate what they did to me I'm gonna
write a character about them and I'm
gonna show everybody just what a piece
of crap human being this person is and
when this person watches the movie
they're gonna go oh my God that's me I
need to change my life so that's the
original intent and then I start working
on the character and I start massaging
the character and then I start to
realize oh crap I have empathy for the
character and then I develop more and
more empathy and I'm like oh crap that
character is part of me
um the character may never really grow
in the story may still be a piece of
crap in the story but I develop empathy
for why they're not good people but as
far as the layers of an evil person
having virtue and a virtuous person
having evil
I think it's I I want to tackle both of
those both of those intrigue me
to no end because there is a flip side
to everything there's so it's um
it's uh and I don't think
I I would actually The Virtuous person
who has
who's not getting in touch with the evil
would intrigue me more than working with
on an evil person that has virtue
because because there's um
the the with uh with a virtuous person
they're they're actively pushing down
that evil where with with an evil person
they're actively going I'm virtuous no
really I'm virtuous
can you think of any characters that
bring to mind that are evil that you
actually have empathy for I know a lot
of people have talked about the Joker
but that you go you know what maybe this
person there's you have some soft spot
for that person yeah well the evil
characters I mean for the most part the
antagonist
um if it's a like a like a superhero
movie or a James Bond or a mission
impossible the the antagonist has to be
more interesting than the hero I think
uh that the layers got to be there and
then then we're like how is the hero
going to get through this
um so I find uh the K do I have empathy
for the for the hero for the antagonist
um and those kind of hero type movies
um I think I just get a kick out of how
evil they are and I'm like happy they're
evil because I'm sitting there enjoying
their evilness and how how is Tom Cruise
going to get through blank blank blank
um you know in the in those in those
total formula movies that I just adore
beyond belief I know they're not going
to die at the end that's not the
question the question is how are they
not going to die that's what that's what
keeps us watching
why is evil important and storytelling I
think we're intrigued with eagle evil I
think
if we I mean you know I grew up in a
very religious household so there's the
Bible the Bible is just all evil this is
bad this is bad this is bad don't do
this and there's there's a lot of and
then they go through this there's so
many evil stories in the Old Testament
you're like wait God's telling you to
kill your own son you know there's
there's um
I think our Collective mythology has
just a ton of evil in it and
um we may try to paint it as like oh no
no we're all good we're all good but you
think about you know how we got here and
what's going on and evil is the theme uh
you know Genghis Khan man you know that
guy's a hero of his narrative but what
did he do
um actually I can't remember what did he
do he pillaged he pillaged and you know
it's like the Norwegians uh the Vikings
you know what did they do you know they
were they're Heroes of their own stories
but they're decimating cultures
so um
I I think I think it's a general
Narrative of
what uh
what we should explore
um
and that's and then how and then how are
we coping with
the evil around us and then how are we
coping how are we coping with
empathizing with evil things you know
and there's times when there's beautiful
times and I have evil thoughts even if
I'm just driving around Los Angeles and
I'm like that person who cut me off
probably shouldn't exist on this Earth
there's a little joy to having that
fantasy even though we don't act out the
fantasy but we do get to write down the
fantasy so
uh I I think I don't think um you know
we don't go through the whole day with
all virtuous thoughts I was I was just
at Starbucks getting a cup of coffee and
this idiot in front of me is like had
this huge two different credit cards you
know all these all these stipulations to
his order all he got was one drink and
one thing I thought he was an Uber Eats
guy and this guy's just and I'm going
and I'm sitting there going that guy
might be you know it's part of the human
Collective he may be dispensable and
then it's just you know it's it's a fun
thought to think about but in real life
we never do it and then if I followed
him home I would see that he's not a
good father to his kids and he was just
having a rough day so that's you know
there's
where there's um
evil and there's empathy we need we need
the whole we I guess we need the whole
story and that's why we tell the story
we need the whole story to map out the
the whys of uh he was the antagonist in
my life for five minutes because my
venti coffee was late
okay no I I talk about going way out no
I I saw someone at a store the other day
trying to return something but quote
didn't have the credit card and was
arguing and the workers were very nice
and they said I'm really sorry sir if
you come back with the credit card
you'll be fine no no I need service and
and wouldn't take no for an answer and
in that moment I'm looking at the person
like okay this is weird and doesn't seem
right
but who knows maybe legitimately it
didn't have the credit card and it just
you had the receipt
or they shouldn't be on this Earth
anymore they had all this stuff but my
point is I mean we we see uh we used to
see tabloids and we would see evil there
and now we can go on social media and
now we're all judges of what's evil
um even if it's one video of somebody
pushing someone in a convenience store
yeah and we don't know what happened on
the other end to prom we don't know we
just see that one snippet you know and
so now we're watching evil played out in
in real life quote unquote but we don't
know who really was the offending party
who was the first one to sort of prompt
something so and that's just that's
that's really intriguing because that's
all point of view so we're getting we're
getting uh everyone tells their own
truth and I'd rather have I'd rather
have that in fiction and on the page and
be able to work it than to uh try to
understand the real uh social media
conflicts that we get you know that's
where I'm just like
uh I I'm skeptical of all of them
looking for writers to go to Dark Places
I used to think that it was important to
live
um I
one of my favorite writers is William T
vollman and he's a guy that would go to
the would stay in the tenderloin and
stay at a um house to you know and and
do crack and um he and he's actively
said these things so I even interviewed
him it's
um it's published but
he would actively go to these places and
and I thought you know what I need to do
what he does not not to the crack end
but
I needed I want needed to be around
certain elements that were dark in order
to get inspiration and I've I realized I
don't I really don't
um
it's uh
there's dark everywhere we don't need to
seek it out there's there's dark amongst
us
um
and you know it's and maybe that's why
vorman's written so many more great
books than I've ever written maybe maybe
maybe I'm doing it wrong and he's doing
it right when he goes
um I mean she's he embeds himself in war
and does a lot of he's he's uh
what he does is gets there and feels it
and needs to know the whole story but
that's what he's writing I'm not writing
that and I don't need to
I don't need to essentially try to lose
my mind if I'm working on a character
that's trying to lose their mod that
that's losing their mind and then go
wait a second I need therapy three times
a week now uh it's just I think what I
need to do
is to uh and what all writers need to do
is just go what's my personality who am
I I don't need to try to be someone else
I you know I would love to be a woman
but I'm not a woman so it's uh
within my parameters and my daily life
the dark doesn't the dark comes to us no
matter what I I don't it's
anyone who seems as privileged and you
know wealthy and thinking it seems like
they have it all together no there's
dark there they don't need to go move
into a dark area they they have a wealth
of
um
they have a wealth of material that they
can build from from their own experience
and
a sort of Gonzo journalism Hunter S
Thompson approach you don't have to
necessarily take that but what about
recounting dark stories do you find
sometimes with your students that they
have a tough time or there's others that
they can't turn it off that it's like
flows like a a bad faucet well the the
problem with the true stories that come
in with my students is they say oh no
this really happened and this is true
and I'm like but it's not interesting
enough you're not you're not putting
enough conflict in there uh so it's
usually this happened and this made me
really upset and I'm like okay yeah but
make me care so you can it could be
based on something true but to make that
particular
event that was true to you and dark to
you to make it Universal you're going to
have to really kind of dissect it you're
going to have to move maneuver it around
you're going to have to
um
play with it and massage it to get the
essence of what happened we need the
emotional essence of what happened we
don't need the play-by-play so when it
comes to true things that happen I think
a lot of the times when I'm dealing with
students is get out of the play-by-play
what's the what's the what's the
emotional effect that you're trying to
get through because that's more there's
more truth
to conveying the emotion than just
showing the play-by-play because we want
to get to the hearts of our uh of our
readers and audience
do you think that sometimes we think a
story is interesting and it's not
it's not really that
well or that any any story can be
interesting even if it's just someone
waiting in line for coffee and there's a
person who's paying with two credit
cards and needing special attention
um yeah it's uh I think um
I think every story is interesting but
it has that's when the idea that's when
the idea comes up this idea sounds good
but it has to be put on the page the the
idea that's not put on the page is not a
fleshed out idea so
um there uh who wrote that book it was
the whole book is the timeline of the
book is a guy on an escalator
going down or up the escalator I think
it's called mezzanine and I can't
remember the author's name right now
um and that sounds like a very boring
book if you were to pitch that oh yeah
this whole book is based on a guy going
down an escalator in a mall
um that's like well that doesn't sound
interesting put it on the page though
craft it and it becomes something that
people are engaged with so I think we
can knock out our
you know we I I find joy in in the most
mundane things and then I'll write them
down and then as I keep writing them and
massaging them then I'll be like oh wait
there is something in there there's
something in the mundane
oh that's cool but it ha I mean it has
to be written uh for uh for anything to
happen that's so
you know if I were to write that story
about the guy at Starbucks
um probably most the story would be
based on what a terrible eye what person
I am but from but not you know I that's
how I would approach it but I wouldn't
approach it from that point of view I
would approach it as the hero of the
story but it would be dissecting
everything that's terrible about my
thought process while
as I'm writing the protagonist that's me
um that protagonist is not going to know
that their thought process is terrible
and then that's where comedy will
probably come in because
you know the the or you know the urge to
do all these certain things I'll look
back at it and I'll be like that's when
I find the empathy in other people and I
know and I realize the stupidity of
myself and the stupidity is glorious and
he's just like this is pretty presumptu
this presumptuous you know who am I to
judge and it's just like that's that's I
think that's the juice that's a lot of
fun for me
what is plot great question plot is
conflict
um so
well we need the character first I I for
me I always need the character first
sometimes though I do come up with a
with a situation first and plot's kind
of a situation but we do have to put the
character in the situation so we put a
character in a situation and the
character has a goal
and you know great the character has a
goal and then the character moves
forward to that goal and we throw
obstacles at that character and that's
plot how is the character going to move
through those obstacles will they will
they make the right or wrong decision
will they learn from that decision
that's That's essential a plot is to me
is throwing obstacles at the character
and then seeing how they get out of them
For Better or For Worse and then how
they move on to the next scene so that's
when uh
that's that's that's when the beauty of
creating the plot and essentially
creating the three-act structure that
kind of turns into this huge showdown at
the end but we need to know how the
character gets in and out of obstacles
throughout the whole
movie and then that's when that's that's
adding to the plot it's all pointing to
One Direction when we get to that
when we get to that Showdown so
how would you teach plot right now if
I'm a new student and in class and
like a sort of a Reader's Digest version
of uh I I like to come up with I like to
come up with um really lame like like
the lamest situation like I'll say so
let's say your character uh wants a
wants to buy gum okay great that's you
know any because any any goal
as long as the characters totally
invested in the goal makes sense so
the character Wants to Rule all of the
world great if the character wants to
stick a gum great but but it needs to
mean just as much to that character to
get that stick of gum so let's get them
a stick of gum great the stores across
the street now
um as your character walks walks to get
that stick of gum what can you do to
make it harder for them to get that
stick of gum and then I throw it to my
students and it's just like let's just
be absurd let's be totally absurd what
would you do I get a baseball bat and I
knock him in the knees great knock them
in the knees beat those beat those
kneecaps out but that character still
needs that gum and we're gonna love that
character for using his elbows to try to
get to that store to get to the gum what
can we do next and
so we can create a um we're creating
plot by just throwing essentially uh you
know rocks at this character who wants
something so bad
um and it's so the that's where there's
a lot of fun
I have a lot of fun discussing plot with
my students because it's just like let's
come up with the silliest scenarios and
then great now when you go to your scene
where the woman wants the wants the man
to ask her on a date but she's not sure
what he thinks of him the the stakes are
just as high as if someone wants a piece
of gum or someone wants to be the ruler
of the world now what are the obstacles
you're going to put in and then when
they have a character worksheet they
know the flaws and the strengths of
their characters then they know how to
like bring all of that in heighten it
beyond belief and then we we're gonna
watch that scene and be like is he gonna
ask her out or not uh so that's
essentially a plot to me
okay and then should I be writing this
like sidebar thing that no one's going
to see that I'm going to know about the
convenience store clerk
and that's going to help set up the
maybe the tension in the scene so our
protagonist is going to run in and
they're going to Fumble for change for
this gum and there's going to be
something about this clerk that's going
to now add new conflict maybe that clerk
used to be a CEO and they were let go
and and and this is a job they got and
they remember this person because that
was one of their employees
and now I mean so but but necessarily
the or the the audience will know that I
have all this backstory but there's
going to be a tension there
yeah and as long as I I feel like as
long as
the story stays on the protagonist who
wants the gum and then this is another
this is another obstacle so they
actually make it to the store after all
of my all of my students have thrown in
all their uh you know we're gonna take
out his tongue and his teeth he won't be
able to chew gum okay what are we gonna
do there
um and then yeah you add even more
tension when we get to the store we can
have we can have another
antagonist of sorts uh blocking the
actual getting of the gum or or that
that maybe we maybe the protagonists get
to help or maybe the clerk is a helper
in the situation and then we and um
because our you know our heroes do need
helpers along the way
and then
um but then we'll lose that helper but
it's and that's when we have the
victories and the losses if we give too
much losses if we're throwing too much
loss at a character then um then we'll
lose our audience but we get that
character that Victory it's like oh the
gum great what's next
um that's what we need we need to ask
the question what's next and we also
need to give them we need to give them a
moment to breathe and go
ah we got the gum you know and then uh I
I don't know where to go from there and
because that's such a simplistic story
but that's yeah that's the victories and
losses and when I work with my students
when they do their beat sheets I try to
I'm like no where the victories are
nowhere know where your breaths are
because you need to give your character
uh oh all right I got this and but
that's the last thing they got because
the next thing's coming up and gonna hit
them even harder it's like fix that and
then boom next so
so do you find a lot of uh writers maybe
they're more intermediate they're
they're not letting it breathe enough
they know hey I need conflict and I need
to buy this point but now they're
they're infusing too much conflict
I it's I think it's better to have more
conflict than less because it's it's
it's a lot of fun to throw the conflict
in there and then pull it out and go
that's too much that's too much
um where uh yeah and and sometimes
people ask it feels so manufactured and
I'm like it is manufactured you know it
feels fake it is fake it's just like it
this isn't this isn't real life this go
ahead and feel awkward about it not
feeling real because you just keep
crafting it and crafting it and in the
world of in the building of the world of
and this is one you know people talk
about World building and science fiction
movies or other things there's World
building romantic comedies there's World
building in every single movie so Build
That World stay in the confines of the
world and then um yeah and let them run
let the let the characters run right
because if you want to go to you know
Mystic Pizza or pretty woman or whatever
that mean mean there was World building
and all that you have a small New
England town this restaurant you got is
it Conchita Farrell she was like she ran
the restaurant and it's you know it's
kind of a fun atmosphere but it's no
nonsense and and they're waiting for
this food critic to come in that they're
all terrified of that's gonna either
make or break the restaurant so you know
they're getting ready before the shift
they're polishing whatever
um and so now we feel like okay I'm in
this small town I know that this
restaurant means everything to this
owner and and you know there when the
food critic comes in they're all smiles
and it's probably overly you know
they're giving too much attention yeah
so
um not even sure where I'm going with
that I think I just well I explained all
of Mystic Pizza sorry right and I still
need to watch the film actually I feel
bad please I need to watch it but
but you said you you said exactly the
thing
um it's it's the um it's everything they
want it's their whole their character we
don't need to know that they have these
other wants in their lives you know are
they sexually satisfied in this
relationship that we're not seeing off
screen who cares we need to know that
that restaurant critic coming in is the
most important piece of their life
sure sure and there might be a little
bit of that in Mystic Pizza too yeah
what do you say to writers who tell you
that plot doesn't matter there are
writers who say plot doesn't matter
there might be
um I think
well I I was the what you asked me like
think of some movies that meant
everything to you uh in one of our email
exchanges and I was thinking of Stranger
Than Paradise the Jim jarmouche film and
um and the reason that meant to
everything to me is because I saw it
when I was a kid on the PBS affiliate in
San Francisco channel nine
yes for some odd reason they why they
showed it over and over again they said
this is only 67 takes and blah blah blah
but it made me realize that a movie is a
craft and not just that's when I kind of
that's when I got the separation went oh
wow and like a movie like that seems
plotless and a lot of it is plotless to
an extent
or is it
I'm I'm am I thinking of the one where
they have they open with the two Elvis
enthusiasts on a train the gym German
that's uh mystery trained oh okay
because I love that one too and then
they go in this hotel and okay all right
no that's a lot more that is a lot more
plot this is the one with uh John Lurie
and um
where they're just his Hungarian cousin
comes to stay with him in uh Brooklyn
and it's uh yeah it's like there's plot
in there so I it's um I like what what
film wouldn't have
what can you think of a film that
doesn't have plot okay I know I'm not
supposed to use this reference Dinner
with Andre My Dinner with Andre does
that have plot I haven't seen it you
haven't seen it okay well there
yeah I can't use that reference anymore
but I think they're but I think I I know
the you know I know the actors in it and
I remember seeing clips of it they do
want something that's true and if they
want something do they get it are they
are they are they having a conversation
where they
um where they shift the
um
where they where they shift the idea in
the other person's mind uh where the
other person has a oh I didn't think of
it that way a moment
um or are they just kind of coming at
each other with this is me this is me
this is me this is me
um
so yeah well that's why I haven't seen
my Dinner with Andre because there's no
plot why would I watch that no
apparently it did very well but uh but
I'm just thinking that I'm just thinking
of that from from a long time ago but
yeah it's I mean and that's just it's
it's hard to come up with an example of
a movie that doesn't really have plot
even if it's you know I love I love slow
Scandinavian films I love I mean there's
this author T singer that I read his
books and they're about nothing and it
just it brings me absolute joy and the
plot is like a little bit
um there's even there's even YouTube
channels that show Norwegian trains just
going from Oslo to Bergen and I'll watch
it and so it's it might be there's no
plot there but there is forward momentum
there's no obstacles
but there's forward momentum so maybe
that's maybe that's the um
an example of a reason not to have plot
uh I you know where yeah I'll watch
something but I think I watch it more
for artistic reasons than I do for like
oh my God I can't wait till they I can't
wait till they get to you know uh
Stavanger it's no I barely care so it I
think I think I don't care but I enjoy
that makes sense yeah there's great uh
Norwegian um or Scandinavian in general
YouTube channels where they talk about
you know different Christmas uh you know
customs and things like that and they
are really fascinating to watch how they
put it together yeah it's very artistic
no I could watch Dolphins just go in and
out of the water for two hours and I'll
be you know in the march of the Penguins
I mean
What a Beautiful film uh there you know
I if I remember right there is plot to
it because they are going somewhere to I
think it's it's all about the
reproduction and the likes they have to
take so there are very high stakes in
the march of the Penguins and it's
presented to us in a you know kind of a
light-hearted way but um but there's
still Stakes there yeah I think uh I I
would not be interested in filmmakers
who don't who think that there's no
reason for a plot um
that even even a photographer has to
have
uh a plot you know a photographer is
telling a story they're they're trying
to frame they're trying to frame a photo
they're they're looking for conflict
they're looking for they're looking for
how
how to present it and it just made you
know then to one person that just like
oh it's a picture of a face but if you
talk to the photographer they'll tell
you what the um what the tension is and
then so that we do need tension I think
for those writers that do believe in and
plot when it comes to plot how can a
writer figure out what isn't working
for uh um it's
I think that's in later rewrites
throw it all in there and then um
and then and what I what I do is I is uh
after I I outline more after than I do
before so then I outline the scenes and
I kind of I was I want the I want the
scenes to uh you know I kind of think of
it as a DJ so you know the the
the heavy conflict here is a nine and
then let's get it back down to a four
then let's bring it up to a seven as you
know it's uh I used to DJ at bars and
stuff too in San Francisco with my
crates of vinyl I want to keep the Dance
Floor going so how do I keep the Dance
Floor going I can't you know smash cut
you know uh you know uh I'm blanking on
Fiona Apple to AC DC I probably can but
but how does how do they stay on the
dance floor so then they go buy more
drinks so I get more money at the end of
the night from the place
um so I think it's just about it's about
curating the scenes and then
um
and and just and and also the scene has
to make as you get towards your final
draft
the scene has to make a case for itself
is this does the scene even make it into
the movie
and it and I find it really intriguing
that
this yes it makes it into the movie Yes
it gets shot yes it gets into post and
even those scenes get cut and
um and so
the there's there's a reason those
scenes are written even if we have to
take them out when we're in the
screenwriting process there's a reason
those scenes are filmed even if they
have to be taken out during
post-production and I don't know what
that reason is and there's probably
producers going we're losing money and
when you do this but at the same time
those actors have to the actor and
director have to work through that scene
that never makes it into the movie but
that may inform how another scene is
shot or how a character com actor comes
at uh their angle on another scene and
for some I I feel like there's no um
they're they're you know there's a lot
on the there's a there's a lot of pages
that you wrinkle up and throw away and
you're just like that didn't work but
you need it to get to where it works you
need it you need those and you need to
embrace those pages and you need and
just go wow yeah you almost have to say
thank you to the bad writing because the
bad writing gets you to the good stuff
would you play Closing Time
the end of your DJ sets I yeah the last
I mean I haven't DJ'd in so many years
but the last ones I did um
was uh I'd throw on a Frank Sinatra or
Tom Jones oh wow after you know after
I've kept the whole Dance Floor going
and it's just kind of like now we're
mellowing out you know we're bringing it
down okay so yes the bartenders are
trying to do all their work to clean up
and the last call Ding last call I'm
just like
so in a movie though you're also you're
you're winding down the audience whether
it's a house wind down or or a sad one
or in some foreign film sort of an
ambiguous ending where we don't really
know right when it comes to plot and
then the wind down happens and we're a
few minutes from the end
um is there really a bad ending is there
an ending that
this is not textbook how it should have
been you know if if it's a happy story
sad whatever yeah as I think um
there's there's a film I just watched
where I was like oh that ending was so
horrible I can't remember what film it
was darn it and it was a good film
um
there's a lot of films I really love and
I'm like oh you blew in the ending
um and uh
but as far as like as far as the stakes
of act three and the stakes of the high
tension and then we need the brat we all
need to sit in it we all kind of need to
sit and relax and go
wow and we have to do that with the
characters on the screen and with
everyone there's a there's a movie that
I bring to class especially my beginning
classes I make everyone and I've watched
this hundreds of times because I make
everyone completely dissect every single
scene in it it's Little Miss Sunshine
and in Little Miss Sunshine I I actually
have the I get the DVDs of the movie
because I don't like you know so I'm the
DVD collector but they also have the
extras on there and they have the
deleted scenes and there was like one or
two extra scenes at the end of the movie
that they completely shot
um where there was like where they're
like well that was crazy they're they're
like in a rest stop and they're all on a
bench and they're all talking
everything's just gone great and so oh
what do you want a hamburger
and they shot this whole scene but the
end of the movie is the bus driving away
and
you know it's the some people sometimes
you don't know what the end of the movie
is until it's way in post-production uh
and and they didn't know they thought
they needed these tagons they there's
there's a lot of times where
um filmmakers feel like they need to uh
to hold the hand of the audience a
little more and the audience can hold
their own handle a lot of times the
audience can get it uh we don't have to
um
we don't have to uh kind of push it on
them now feel like this it's just like
no stop
that that was good enough
you're fine uh take a breath and think
about that
I like that is do you think that just
only comes from seeing the actors play
out that scene that it's hard to tell on
the page
um
I don't know if it's hard yeah it could
be hard to tell on the page and
we're just trying to write the best
story we can with
um it's funny so with Confessions of a
Teenage Jesus jerk I was
from the final draft I was very adamant
about the ending
um and I was like this is the ending
this is it and uh and there was a scene
that was
um asked to for afterwards and I'm just
like
no
I didn't want to write it and I and it
had to be written
and then they shot it and then it didn't
make the film it didn't make the final
cut and for some odd reason maybe it did
need to be shot so maybe you know maybe
I I've done so many things wrong and my
Approach has been you know sometimes my
Approach isn't the greatest approach
sometimes I could be a little friendlier
and a little more amicable and go oh
you're right let's just do that and see
what happens
um but with this I was so
sure that that was the end but the the
people involved weren't sure and it's
okay that they're not sure and so just
let people not be sure and then
you know pray and post that it all works
out and and it may have been that you
know depending on how the tone of the
film went because when that edit when
it's in the editing room it's being the
whole story is being told Again by an
editor so
um they may have needed to get that on
camera just in case they kept different
scenes in there or they had to lose
scenes and but to get the whole tone of
the film they went nope that was the
ending
um so
there's
there's so many elements to how to end a
movie I mean I guess there it's and so
much of that stake so on the page the
best you can do and then does it end up
in the Final Cut who knows
um because there's so many
uh you know there's so many factors
involved so so that's interesting you
you resisted sort of the suggested
ending they wanted an extra scene at the
end and then it ended up not happening
and you ended up agreeing that that was
actually a good thing to have that extra
scene no no they shot the scene and and
then but but I won and then I won
because they that scene Hit The Cutting
Room floor so the movie ended exactly as
I wanted it to end
does that make sense yeah and I wasn't
sure if you wanted The Cutting Room
floor one you actually agreed with them
oh okay no no no I still I did I still
didn't agree and when I when I was sent
the rough cut as I was coming to the end
um I was going yeah I had a I had to cut
to Black it was cut to Black like cut to
Black cut to Black got the black boom
cut to Black and I was like yes so um it
was uh
you know and there were and there were
other battles that I had where I was
like okay this is right and then and I
was totally wrong and so it's it there's
that's the beauty of the the
collaboration of um have those
disagreements
um because as the writer you know oh
yeah I can like pretend like I know
everything but I don't once you what's
your once you're on set what you're with
a director once you're seeing actors
it's it's you you really got to kind of
let things go and uh yeah the only thing
I was so I was really adamant about was
how the how it was going to end and I
just I saw that from the beginning and
um and it wasn't it didn't make
anyone feel comfortable so maybe
everyone needed to feel comfortable and
then they went no wait that's right the
ending is
um the cut to Black
how did fear of success almost ruin your
writing career oh fear of success ruins
my writing career every day
it's um
yeah it's there's there's multiple fears
there's fear of success there's fear of
failure
um
and I think I still self-sabotage myself
uh
I have to get into a world of um
it's a weird world of delusion where
it's I know I'm writing the greatest
thing ever told to man and through all
of human history except it's also a
piece of crap at the same time
um so
you know fear I mean I guess there's
there's fear of success and fear of
failure yeah it was I I used to
I used to write everything with an Oscar
speech planned uh and and that Oscar
speech was more of who you know it
wasn't who I was gonna think it was who
I hated and I was just gonna tell I was
going to bring all my resentments out
you know and it's it's uh
it's silly and it's absurd to think
about but it would be fun to do an Oscar
speech but then you kind of look at it
and go ah but would it be really fun to
go to the Oscars uh
um
but yeah fear fear of success uh
it's weird because I've had very minor
success I don't I don't have a you know
I don't feel like I have
I feel grateful for the success I've had
but in my very minor success it's
sometimes it's a little disconcerting uh
or
um we're just like oh crap yeah that's
out there for people to see
oh
um and I forget uh and but at the same
time that's wonderful so what a you know
what a bourgeois
problems
are you gonna go to Starbucks and pay
with two credit cards after this I'm
gonna pay with two credit cards I'm
gonna ask for water and I'm gonna put
ice in it and I'm like you're gonna have
to take this back and not put ice in
this okay right yeah
um
do you almost feel guilty if things go
well for you
what yes oh my God I have therapy
tomorrow too we're going to talk about
all of this I think a lot of that though
it does have to do with I grew up a
Jehovah's Witness so
um there is a lot of guilt in succeeding
especially in the entertainment industry
there's a lot of uh there's a lot of
fear involved I'm working through that
actually constantly I'm working through
the mud The Merc and the mud of growing
up uh in a way where I was supposed to
be not part of this world and I wasn't
supposed to buy into any of it and my
whole life was supposed to be devoted to
the church so
um I've been out for many years but it's
still back there and I still it still
comes up so
um and not that my story is totally
unique I think a lot of people have a
have a rough time with it because
especially you know where you come from
working class family and you know it's
my grandfather Grandpa Duchesne I you
know he lived a mile away from me in San
Francisco in the last five years of his
life I stopped talking to him because I
would go over there and he'd he would um
insult me for my choices and saw me for
writing didn't understand why I didn't
have a union job like he had and
um and it was constantly insulting and I
was and I'm like I have enough of my own
self-doubt I don't need to be put down
so much so I basically cut him off out
of my life and
um and it was it's sad but I had to do
it because
he wanted me to just be weighed down and
then plus he doesn't understand there's
not there's not a lot of money coming in
this is this is all an act of Faith but
it's also not even on the Act of Faith
it's a um
it's uh it's a have to when you realize
you're a writer
you have to write and it doesn't matter
if anything gets published and it
doesn't matter it's I'm a crappy person
if I'm not actively writing and in order
to not be a crappy person in this world
I'm gonna keep writing and then I'll be
nicer to be around
so interesting so when you see a student
in one of your classes or a zooms you
know sort of relationship and you can
tell like this person has some Talent it
just needs some refining but I'm seeing
they almost they feel guilty about like
they feel like shameful that they have
talent
what do you do to help them sort of come
out of that or you don't you figure
that's their own process you don't want
to rush it
yeah I mean I just there's great
talented people that come through
um I'm there I'm there to I'm there to
help them with their craft and I'm there
to give them and to cheerlead them
but at the same time I'm also not their
therapist so if they if they have guilt
if they you know I could come back I can
come in with hey this is what how this
is what I've worked through and this is
and I usually and this is what a lot of
writers work through I'm I get to you
know I get to interview best-selling
authors all the time and they always
feel like they have imposter syndrome
they can have 22 best-selling books out
that blank page still scares the crap
out of them but the one thing
that they have ahead of the person that
has never written a book is they
remember the 22 best sellers every blank
page scared the crap out of them and
then it went to a bestseller so they
know I remember this feeling and I'm
still gonna do it uh and I think that's
essentially all writing is to just know
that it doesn't feel good for a while
and then it feels good here and there
and then it doesn't feel good
um and it's uh yeah I wish it was sexier
than that but it's not
you said just jokingly you always feel
shame writing something why is that uh
yeah that was was that a Freudian slip
um I don't know if I
I don't always feel shame I just think
that there's just a feeling of um
it's it's a it's a it's the working
class in me it's the working class
family background it's why are my hands
not calloused and why are my joints not
aching at the end of the day
um where
um I've I've I've completely ruined the
tradition of the duches
um I'm not monkey wrenching under a car
um monkey wrenching with a with a light
felted pen a legal paper and you know
you can actually make money and a living
doing this how absurd is this it's uh so
maybe maybe my joke was probably more uh
because I was hiding the fact that uh I
it's not it's just weird to be a writer
and from where I've grown up it's it's
weird to do anything that's not um
mechanical or you know has has Union has
uh you know very strong union that uh
so-called strong union that but I wasn't
sure if you meant to also exposing uh
thoughts and things about yourself that
even if they aren't really that you know
controversial that it's just you're
letting people know your thought process
right so um that shame I kind of don't
have uh because my philosophy is if it
scares me it's the right thing so I'll
write things that scare me I'll write
things that I don't want anyone to ever
know about me in my life
and but when I have that feeling of oh
my God nobody could ever know this
that's when I know I have to write it
that's that's when I know I have to go
there and it's just hilarious that once
those things come out people go I I feel
that way too uh and and it's everyone is
just like how did you write that I can
never write that but I feel the exact
same way so um the the beauty of just
going to the scary places I think that's
that's what I and I don't enjoy it but I
do it and when I'm when I'm scared to do
it I know I'm doing something right I
know I'm heading in a good direction
what's more difficult writing a novel or
writing a screenplay oh good question
there
they're both very different for me for
so for me I always write I write out
scenes so I don't write it I don't go
straight to the screenplay I can write
the whole scene and then I can I then I
convert it to the screenplay so I'm kind
of always adapting
um Pros to a script which is probably
the worst way to write a script but it's
kind of the way I approach it so for me
the novel is always
um
the novel is always most important to me
if someone said you you gotta you gotta
make a choice right now are you writing
novels for the rest of your life are you
writing a screenplays for the rest of
your life I immediately novels that's it
I'm good
um but I love film and I love the artist
screenwriting
um and
I they both have their challenges the
the Beauty and the and they're both
beautiful in their own ways the beauty
of the novel is
if you screw up a novel
you screwed up the novel and your name
is on that if you may if it's a great
novel
it's a great novel and your name is on
that so when you're the screenwriter if
the movie doesn't do that well there's
hundreds of people that could have
you know been part of the problem the
movie does great there's hundreds of
people that could have been part of the
greatness so there it's it's one's a
team sport and one's a solo sport
um
I I can in both of them
in screenwriting it's a solo sport when
you're writing your script so I thrive
in that and then but I also thrive in um
problem solving I want them to go
through and give me notes and go you
know scene 23 cut that out scene 42 we
need this and I'm like great and I need
to know my screenplay back and forth so
I'll be like scene 23 we cut that out
that means that we're going to lose
scene 18 and this in the breadcrumb from
scene three and so it's that I love
getting in the technical part of that
and I guess I do it with both
um I don't
I don't find um I don't you know they're
both separate but they're both so the
same because we're both they're both
putting it on the page if that makes
sense so with screenwriting it's like a
game of Jenga so if you're pulling
something from the bottom that that's
not going to make sense and and the
whole thing could topple unless it's
properly weighted it's got to be it's
got to be constructed properly or else
yeah the whole thing is going to fall
down yeah same with the novel I mean you
could totally screw up a novel by you
know going going too much or too little
there's the the technicals of it are
similar it's uh they just both have to
be crafted
um and the the beauty the beauty of
Cinema is I mean and we I think I see it
a lot you see bad screenplays that are
good films because the directors and the
actors come in and if you just really
sat there and
read the screenplay and then you watch
what the actors and the directors
brought to it and you go
wow what a crap screenplay but what a
beautiful film and um there's there's a
lot of bad screenwriters out there that
make great movies you know it's uh it's
such an interesting game yeah
what about prose writing and thought
process versus screenwriting and thought
process in terms of showing the
characters going through something in
their mind
they yeah that's when it was so when
we're when we're on the screenplay
that's when
um
that's when we have to show uh we we
show a lot less there's a lot more
breathing room so uh the the novel where
we're bringing we're bringing the reader
through the novel and through all the
internal process thought processes and
the screenplay where taking the
characters there but
we also have to let the director do
their job and the actors do their job
and we just kind of have to and just
give a little bit of intention a little
bit of note this happens this happens
they don't need to in the novel it could
be oh why this happened and it could go
around this way but it's it's um get the
essence of it just really put the
emotional Essence in there and not too
much emotional Essence because let the
let everyone
um let everyone do their job and they're
gonna and the and the the great
directors do great work and the great
actors do great work and if you do put
too much in there you could be
impeding what they need to do on uh on
their end as as part of their job
do novels and screenplays have the same
structure
uh screenplays are I don't know because
you can really screw around with a novel
structure you can't screw around with
the screenwriting structure and anyone
who's like
um oh wow this is experimental and you
look at it and yeah no it's still 3x and
I can tell you exactly where those act
breaks are
because it's hard to break that
pattern we know we've been told these
stories through film for over a century
a certain way and if you know if the
First Act goes 45 minutes
the audience may not understand that the
First Act is going 45 minutes but
they'll understand that there's
something wrong with the film and I
think I could just go to the bathroom
and get a some popcorn right now and
they won't know why
um so we are really structured to have
uh the the hero on the singular Journey
for the most part and the ACT breaks and
the escalating attention as it is with
you know with the novel you can
uh Daniel epsky's House of leaves just
that that book right there just you know
that turns the novel on its side but
it's a novel we can really
there's so much you can do to a novel
that uh that can't be done on screen as
there's so much you can do on screen
that can't be done to a novel I mean you
can there's you know you you don't
describe an actor I mean you don't in
the you don't describe a character
feeling sad and why they feel sad all
you got to do is see a look all you need
is a reaction on an actor's face and
that will tell you what five pages of
the novel can tell you so then that's
when it's beautiful
um on the screen and then when it's
beautiful in the book too
yeah I've been um looking at Walter
tevis's
so the Hustler and then um the Queen's
Gambit and then
um you know it's been a while since I've
actually seen the Hustler but then
seeing Queen's Gambit and just just the
differences just kind of like a lot of
it was very close to the novel maybe it
was cleaned up there were parts that
were cleaned up more
um maybe for certain audiences
um with the Queen's Gambit for for the
series it wasn't as um there were some
details that were maybe too you know
sexually explicit or whatever
um but um you know so just did she still
see the uh chess on the roof she did
yeah I think so but it wasn't totally I
mean it was it was the because that was
where she took these these pills that
yeah she you know went into this world
and that's how she kind of disassociated
and was able to take herself out of the
world of the orphanage in bad situations
and she would see that as a way to not
be in her reality yeah and so um there
was that but yeah it's just interesting
to compare and and you know oftentimes
usually the book it seems like is is
more enjoyable sometimes but then when
you see these characters come to life
and you like the actors yeah uh it's a
whole another experience yeah
yeah anyway I'm not sure where I was
going with that but I'm not sure where
I'm going with anything so I'm glad I'm
on the same page
and we're just having fun here okay so
how does a writer know if prose is
better for them creatively or the
screenwriting format
um I think it's I think they it's just
trial and error
uh I I wrote a screenplay in 2019 right
before covid and
um I was jazzed about it and I'm like
let's go let's go and um I wasn't ready
to show it yet but I knew that I had
because I knew I had rewrites to do and
then now I'm writing the novel
so I read the characters are intriguing
me so much I'm like I really need to get
in their heads and I really and and when
I write I hand write I I'm not a typer
so I have to handwrite everything and
that's um and that's giving me so much
joy right now because that's just like
I'm finding out things about the theme
and what I thought I was presenting and
it was just like oh no that's not the
theme at all so it's uh
yeah it uh if something's a screenplay
or a book it could be both it's
um
and it could be just a novel and some
novels would be you know really hard to
adapt I I but I I think I would like to
think in myself if anyone asked me to
adapt a novel that was unadaptable I
feel like I could find the thread to do
it
um but that's probably because I get a
little delusional and I want to problem
solved so
so you love these characters so much
that you realized that 110 page whatever
screenplay wasn't wasn't enough for you
creatively
yeah um I think yeah I don't know if it
wasn't enough I think there's I don't
think the screenplay is there yet
so that's part of it and I think there's
a lot more to explore and for me the way
to explore it is through pros and
I'm just doing it that way and in the
end I mean it might be a graphic novel
who knows uh I it's almost like you
don't want to you don't want to put it
in a ball too quick let's just let the
story go let's let's see where the story
goes and who you know who knows it maybe
it is just a book maybe maybe it never
was meant to be on the screen at all or
maybe the book gets tossed away and I
learn a couple things and go back in the
rewrite
um I don't think we should I don't think
we should hold on to the the medium so
much that um
you know work through it and try to
complete things but we shouldn't we I
don't think we need to
give the medium so much power let's give
the story The Power
was there a defining book of your
teenage years
so I really couldn't read books in my
teenage years because I grew up the
Jehovah's Witness and I was reading more
bible stuff uh and the and only slid by
in the books that were uh
that were assigned to us in school so
and you know they essentially were like
just try to read enough so you can get
by and get a decent grade and get out it
was it was very discouraged to read
anything that wasn't published by the
Jehovah's Witnesses
um
when
uh so when so what happened was a friend
of mine a friend of mine in the
Jehovah's Witnesses was disfellowshipped
so he was shunned and then he killed
himself and so I went to the elders and
I was looking for help and because I was
because I'm like wait Gibby killed
himself and how can I not kill myself uh
because you know I do have suicide in my
family that's not related to the
Jehovah's Witnesses so
they were completely unhelpful they
didn't want me to grieve his suicide
they just said make sure you keep going
and preaching and stay and that was not
the answer for me so what I did and this
was I think I was 22 or 23.
so so I went to the library instead and
I went to the psychology section and I'm
like where do I get help so I found Tony
Robbins and I found a Wayne Dyer oh yeah
and I'm like and I and I was like oh and
I would just sit there in the stacks and
read these
and it kind of gave me a little bit of
perspective and then it was next to
poetry and I started and I just started
opening poetry books and uh and now it's
just and they were speaking to me and
then somehow the first novel I read was
um Giovanni's room James Baldwin
so I read that book kind of didn't get
it because it's a homosexual love affair
if I remember right I haven't read it
since then
but I got the I got the heart of it
it meant something to me and I was like
who do I read next so James Baldwin was
my number one and then I read Henry
Miller and then I found out that there
was this guy Jack Kerouac who was
grew out on the road and it was it was
the Beat Generation I'm like what's a
beat and I remember skateboarding to the
library before it closed because I had
to get a copy of on the road that
weekend and read it and I read that and
I went and and these were touching me on
emotional levels it was I was having a
conversation with authors that had died
but they were but they were I was having
a conversation that I never got to have
in my life
and that that's what changed everything
and then I read a book called hunger by
Newt ham soon this Norwegian author and
that's when I went I'm a writer that was
the book where I just went that's it I'm
a writer uh and I'm going full in and
even if I can't eat and I have to die
I'm writing till the end
so
and when did you tell family people in
the church that you were a writer
well I was still married and I was
married so I ended up getting married to
a Jehovah's Witness and I was still
married I told her that um
out
and she begged me not to tell anyone and
I didn't and that was very codependent
of me but I was also you know I was also
unhealthy at the time as well but I was
writing at the time and I was and I
started a thing called film junkie and
um and I would go to film festivals I
knew all of a sudden I was a journalist
in 1999 I was like this is all you got
to do so I was going to these see all
these movies before they were raided
because you can't watch rated R movies
in the Jehovah's Witnesses and then I
was writing about all these movies and
then but then they would come out and be
rated R and they'd be like how did Tony
see that and they're like well it wasn't
rated yet and they'd be like oh okay
um when I was kind of out of the um
out of it so I was actively like writing
and working on my own stuff and it was
starting to get seen around and people
would get in touch uh with my wife at
the time and be like Tony's kind of you
wrote something that didn't seem a
little too Christian you know maybe you
should talk to him about it and then I
would lean in harder and write a you
know sex scene so because I was being
very contrarian at the time and I think
I needed essentially I was getting my
teenage angst out when I was 27 which is
just totally embarrassing you need to
get it out in your teen years but it was
a little later for me
so then you moved to LA and you felt
like that you could be your own person
and and that you didn't feel shame about
writing anything oh I feel shame about
writing everything uh you know I did the
LA move didn't happen for a long time I
stayed in San Francisco I was writing
for the San Francisco Chronicle so I was
covering uh books and um music for the
chronicle and I wasn't planning on
moving to Los Angeles
um and then I finished
um Jesus jerk and then I was shopping it
around I got an agent and then I got a
publisher and then so that the book came
out and then the option thing started
happening where things go to die
so so but it but it was beautiful I got
to work with uh producer
um who runs hunting Lane films Jamie
patrickoff and we worked on
the pitch for the TV series and and I
learned so much
um about like writing pitches taking
notes getting and he's very gracious
with me and uh you know and then it was
just like that kind of just fizzled out
there you know there's like meh no screw
it and I don't think it was him I think
it was the people that he had interested
uh and then um
and then the book got to Eric Stoltz and
then that's when
he uh he said hey let's
um first off I found out Eric Stoltz was
reading my book and I was just like well
I could just die now we're done you know
and then um yeah and then
he said uh we need Tony to write the
screenplay so we don't lose the voice
and I went and I went challenge taken
um so I uh yeah I worked on that uh
really hard and hours and hours on end
um
and so I wasn't oh so I wasn't in La yet
I was I was in San Francisco and he was
he's in New York so we were doing a lot
of back and forth that way and then as
it went in it got delayed and then
shooting was supposed to start another
time it got delayed but I knew I had to
be in La for it
um and so I just got down to La when it
was in pre-production and I sublet my
apartment in San Francisco and I just
would sublet around La
while I was in pre-production and then
uh and some months later we were on set
and on location
so that's how I came to La I was already
very far out of the Jehovah's Witnesses
I was already divorced I was I had
already created a writing life in San
Francisco
and I was I knew it was time to leave
San Francisco but I was kind of thinking
New York because
I was writing for Publications and
going on that angle but
um the nudge to La
brought me here which was it turned out
to be the right choice and uh yeah
how does the book business differ to the
film business is it well what what I've
noticed is
in the book world there's um
not a lot of people are there for all
the for all the huge amounts of cash
coming in there there's kind of more of
a a passion like oh crap we might have
picked the wrong thing but this is what
we love
so
when I'm working with like an editor I'm
working with an agent there's a deep
love you know the agent wants to make
money then you know these people yeah
they do want to make money but they're
kind of there
because it's uh it's just what what they
what they know and what they're good at
uh when we get to film there's a there's
a little bit more uh
you know the film business is um
weird I I I I really don't connect with
the film business that much at all I'm
not good at the film business
um and
so it's uh I'm kind of not even good at
pitching you know I'm not good there's a
lot of things I'm really not good at on
the film side of things but um
but I know but I know that I know the I
know my the story is the only thing that
really that I really care about and then
the
maniacal passion to get it out there
when I feel like I've got it right so
and and I've you know people in the
people in the film business they're nuts
they're just absolutely nuts
um and it and what I've learned is it's
just hilarious how people are like oh
yeah no that's I'm Indie you know we
will never do Studio work and it's like
oh we're studio and it's just like there
are pieces of crap on every single layer
and sometimes those Indie sometimes
those Indie focused people are the ones
you don't want to work with at all to be
much better to work at Paramount and
sometimes it's vice versa there's um
the game is just funny there's just uh
what I've learned is
um
you know what what I've learned in my my
small career so far is to uh
is to just love who you work with and
but in the film industry that might not
be an option and have a really good
entertainment lawyer that spells
everything out and you don't even have
to talk to some people sometimes even if
you're working with them just so
well that was going to be my next
question is can you love film and love
you know wanting to put something out
there but not love the business and not
really want to be a part of the business
does that it seems like that can't work
out well I'd love to be a part of the
business where the checks are big that's
my favorite part of the business I would
love to be a part of that
um
hey the business needs to be done and I
understand why the business needs to be
done I mean to create a film is a
Monumental expense and people are
putting their money and going okay let's
make profit and um
so the stakes are very high
and
it's you know I nobody knows what's
going to make it what you know or like
William Gold was it William Goldman or
just like nobody knows anything but they
make good guesses
and there's a lot of people that make
good guesses
um
I I do I mean I love the art of film I
you know I love the passion of someone
who's in wardrobe and to talk to someone
who does wardrobe and and it's just like
they are storytellers there and
I've learned a lot coming into this
where my uh
you know I've Loved film before I love
it even more now that I've seen behind
the curtain so that yeah there's the
business part but but most of this most
of the time if you're really working on
something the business part's so
secondary and you you try to get agents
and entertainment lawyers to do all of
that part of it and then go okay great
here's what I need to do and this is
what I need to deliver and I think a lot
of that is communication too I'm I've I
think I've learned a lot over the years
be very almost over communicative so
they know what to expect so they know
what I can bring and don't promise
anything that I can't bring but let them
know that I'm going to try to do that
but that might be out of my realm but
let's just see what happens kind of
thing so
so then with the literary World maybe
New York old money sort of this this
closed network is that a fallacy it's
much more open now it's it's oh I don't
know yeah um I just might be with the
cool people okay
um I mean
I I don't know on the publishing end I
guess I know just a lot of writers so uh
who you know are just lovely people
whether they're a bestseller every time
they come out or they're on a
you know small print run and I love
both of their styles of writing equally
and love them you know in their own ways
as people so I think maybe I know more
the writing end and I get to kind of be
aloof to the to where the business is I
kind of just don't I don't care too much
and you know I'm dealing with publicists
a lot because I cover writers and the
publicists are great too for the most
part you know they're just passionate
about the the writing and they're they
want to get their they want to get their
authors out there and
um which publicist I've worked with for
20 years you know that that uh they they
know who to give me they just go you're
going to love this guy and I'm like
great you're gonna love this girl I'm
like great I don't even need to see the
book just just yeah they're on the
calendar
so um the the passion for it is there I
want to talk to writers you know I say I
want to talk to right and that's the
lovely thing of doing
a podcast is uh someone you know if I
went hey I want to talk to you to just
that random out of the blue they'd be
like who who are you you have a podcast
and you're like I'd love to talk to that
person for an hour and pick their brain
and it's just like wait you can just do
it it's just it's good fun and that's
drinks with Tony yeah
and you've been doing it how long the
next year will be 20 years so I'm
putting together the 20-year anniversary
party but I did have the Hiatus for five
years between 2013 and 2018. so why the
Hiatus that's when Jesus jerk went into
development and then I had to get to La
and I used to do drinks with Tony in
studio in San Francisco so that was that
was a two-hour show in studio and I
didn't know how to do it not in studio
and then after all the film that for the
film was released and that kind of
um
that that kind of dust settled then I
went maybe I should just do this as a
podcast and have my field recording gear
instead of worrying about
being a doing a two-hour show so I just
kind of switched up the format
the way you miss writing and the way you
feel like you're a better person for
writing and when you don't it's kind of
like the people that meditate they're
like oh if I don't meditate I'm not fun
to be around were you similar with not
being able to do the podcast
did you need did you miss that did you
need to do that podcast
so well uh so after after Jesus jerk
came out and after all the dust settled
I was walking up Hillhurst
totally depressed
I just gutted I didn't know why and I'm
like how do I get out of this depression
and I'm like what's the last thing that
made me happy as I was like you know as
I was working on other writing projects
and stuff but and I went drinks with
Tony
and I think I think because there's no
stakes in it from you there's stakes in
it because I want to do a good show
but there's no there's not the stakes
that I'm putting into my writing and at
the same time
and I and I restarted it with thinking
oh maybe I'll get 10 episodes in I
wasn't planning on doing it that long I
was just like oh I still got this and I
got public publicist contacts I'll just
tell people I'm doing it again and then
when I don't get a guess I'll just stop
and um I just put episode 157 up because
the guests haven't stopped coming and I
have to say no to a lot of people so
it's just like oh um but and I still
enjoy it and the only reason I do it is
because I really enjoy it it's you know
the one in ten guests I go ugh that that
felt like a piece of crap but you know
the nine out of ten I'm just like oh
this is why I do this and there's like
two out of ten where I'm like this is
really why I do this this is this
reminds me of why I'm in this game so
whereas with writing if you don't write
explain to me how long before you suffer
withdrawal
um it's I think it's um I think I think
the thing the thing is is I need to have
characters in my brain and I need
characters
that are coming together
um so I I need to actively be working on
someone so I'm working on a character
Amber right now and so in the during the
day I can have things that irritate me
but I have the problem solving of how
will Amber get out of this situation who
what is Amber what else does what else
does she need
um what what is what does she want to
say to the world so it's it's maybe it's
a way to avoid the the conflict
happening around me where I can kind of
almost meditate on this character that
I'm working on and this you know that I
may that this character actually kind of
don't like but as I'm writing her I'm
writing her completely out of love and
just building around her and you know
she's she's a
yeah I mean what you know this is this
is uh yeah this is a writer in process
on a character but this character does
not make great choices and this
character continues to make great
choices and in the end she still doesn't
make the great choice
she's so there's
um
but working with her and kind of really
getting in her head is just a lot of fun
and just
um and what swirls around her uh is I
find interesting why do you love her if
she makes these bad choices
um I'm well I'm setting up a it's
there's another character that I'm
working on that's going to get the um a
that's going to be more of the
protagonist
and uh
it's a story of three characters but
there's this one character that is more
pivotal than the others so the
characters are around him need to really
be
three-dimensional and now and I also
want you know I love the ambiguity of in
my head she's not making the right
choices but as we get you know as we get
as we move through the story
maybe she is making the right choices
it's it's uh you know it well in the end
she's doing the best she can with the
information she has
but as far as I'm concerned it's that
character is someone that's not
um that's not that hasn't reached the
maturity or reached a certain level of
understanding but has stayed in it and
so I have empathy for that and that's uh
so yeah so driving here I'm I'm just
like driving and I'm thinking of Amber
and people are like oh who who's Amber
is that your girlfriend I'm like no it's
a it's just a word on a page but you
have a vision of what she looks like
what her hopes are what her fears are
what her triggers are yeah yeah yeah and
as I keep writing her I find out more
about her
um and that's that's the joy of
that's the joy of prose writing for me
because I can I can find out if I'm
as I write and I write the scene now and
I go oh
that's why she's doing that you know it
was
I had uh on this particular one in the
in the in the screenplay she's she's
looking in a mirror and reflecting on
herself and that was like the only thing
and as I wrote the thing out
um she's worried about aging
she's in her 20s and she's worried about
aging and um and it's and and that kind
of clicked and I went and it create it
opened her up and it opened the whole
story up in a new way
where it's just like I'm not gonna put
in the screen now if it if if the if the
prose gets thrown away and it stays in
the screenplay I'm not putting in the
screenplay she's worried about aging but
I know she's worried about aging when
she looks in the mirror
she's a model or cocktail waitress or
makeup artist oh okay all right yeah
okay do you ever see her anywhere do you
ever see like oh that was Amber no no I
didn't no I I don't see her I see her
enough I mean when I'm writing the
script you just I see her enough and I
don't want to cast her
um I I like that to be very open but I
do have my thoughts on certain things
um
but as far as like describing exactly
who she is and what she looks like
there's there's just little Composites
here and there and um and I'll take out
like pages from like uh magazines and
stuff and it's there's you know there's
an idea but it's not that but it's there
could be something that um
you know a certain a certain photograph
is just like oh that's kind of an
essence of what she could be
um and yeah it's I'm not one to really
describe I I don't care much about what
they look like I care more about the
insides I guess and then for the film
it's you know there's casting directors
for that who could tell me way better
who could they're much better with at
that gig than I am so
are most great stories and Outsider
story
uh I don't know I mean I feel like I
feel like I'm an outsider and I feel
like almost everyone I know feels like
an outsider at some point in their life
if not often probably more than 50
percent of the time
so maybe that's why we can kind of
gravitate toward Outsider stories
um
yeah and it you know it's we look at a
film like Mean Girls or something and
it's it's about people just trying to be
together and fit in it's we have this
urge to we have this urge to be together
and part of the tribe and so
uh the the
outsider's story is fun to play with but
I don't think any of us want to be an
outsider but it's fun to watch The
Outsider because we kind of can we feel
like we're Outsiders
that makes sense it does I'm trying to
think of the movie I just watched from
the is it Pump Up the Volume the
question oh yeah yeah and so here he's
this radio guy and everybody kind of
worships him because he just says
whatever he wants yeah and they can't
believe what they're hearing and then
you know the The Faculty is just
incensed by it and then in real life
he's this awkward guy that he wants he
he wants to be part of the group but
then he's kind of turned off by that
whole Suburbia High School hierarchy
thing and um just had me thinking about
that just sort of this guy that actually
when you listen to him
he spoke to everyone
but then for whatever reason he was too
scared at the the high school to yeah
try to navigate the
social hierarchy yeah and um but but we
we have these these Hero Stories where
are they always The Outsider I guess
maybe that's what makes the hero's Ark
is that
I guess yeah I guess in order for
I mean for the most part when you know
we have our heroes journey and I think
it's uh singular hero
um I think it's because we could we can
relate to the problems of one person for
90 minutes
um
if you bring in too many people
or you know the the ensemble cast there
tends to be a veering towards the one
person that's really pushing it all the
way through
um so we we have to have that we almost
have to have that mirror who's my mirror
here oh it's Cameron Diaz okay great I'm
with her on this journey
um and that's and I don't think that's
real life in any way at all but for um
well we're all our own heroes in our own
Journeys but we're also a collective but
so I guess our protagonist is an
outsider of sorts because the
protagonist needs to be spun around they
need to be pushed back on their heels
and that's why we're interested it's
just like oh wait they spun around
they're dizzy how do they stop being
dizzy okay that's fun now how do I turn
the page or sit here uh for another 10
minutes to find out what the next two
scenes are because that was interesting
what Peril is this character going to be
in so yeah it would make sense that the
characters would be Outsiders this um
you know during covid we we have all
these uh the the movies I've watched
have not been movies I would watch you
know there are Comfort movies and the
wrong Missy came out the David Spade
movie
um that Adam Sandler uh produced and um
and it's not a movie I'd go run to see
but I watched it and it's just um he is
he is an outsider he's he's in his own
tragedy it's a comedy but he's in the
utter tragedy of
thinking that he found the you know it's
it's really formulaic and like you like
if I just told you two or three
description you'd be like oh so the act
one is this act two is this act three is
this it's like yeah it is but it's fun
to watch him get there what movie
protagonists do you do you feel the most
um connection to
huh
it could be male or female
well so when I was young and this was uh
there was this movie called Johnny swade
Brad Pitt starred in it that came out
and Tom dicillo wrote it and I look at
it now and it's absurd and it's
hilarious but at the time I was I
thought I was Johnny suede I am it's it
was Brad Pitt's first leading role and
um
and it's just about a guy who's
trying to figure out love and wants to
get a band together
I'm like that's me and it's just kind of
silly because it's a um he's really kind
of a Dopey character and not you know I
I don't know why I
gravitated to him so much I think I
think it was because I was trying to
figure out love and um
you know was kind of always wanted to
have you know getting a band together is
like getting a group of friends together
just like how do we how do we how do a
bunch of guys you know
um come together and uh you know not
make love well let's just get a band
it's I it's everything's kind of
intimacy so he was trying to find his
intimacy and blowing it beyond belief
and
um
so when I think of a character that uh I
gravitated to when I was uh when I was
young it was it was Johnny Suede and I
had the
uh yeah it's a Tom de chilo um I got to
interview him like 15 years ago and he's
written books too and I brought every
single book I'm like please sign my
books now he lives in La so uh I still
have to like uh yeah anyway he's he's uh
I'm a huge fan of his and
I'm a huge fan of how honesty is about
um his career as a filmmaker and how
really rough and tumble it was and um
just the beauty of Johnny Suede and his
other movie living in Oblivion which
came out after that so
and sorry you were still in the church
at the time you saw it okay yeah and you
didn't tell anyone that you saw the
movie I was very careful yeah because it
was rated R
um so I had to go to the video store
actually I think I bought the VHS I
bought the VHS and that and I I watched
that thing that's probably the movie
I've seen the most in my life
um and I could probably uh give you
every line of dialogue from here the
reason I watched it was because uh one
of my favorite singers is in Nick Cave
so that was what turned me on to it and
then all of a sudden I'm like well that
character spoke to me so would you hide
the movie Somewhere yes yeah yeah hide
the hide the movies hide the records
um yeah
where would you hide them
um yeah yeah not to I I actually have my
own apartment at that time oh okay so it
was easy enough but when I was like
still living at home it was uh records
were behind the dresser and we would
make mixtapes for our friends and then
we would hide the mixtapes but we would
all trade the tapes and then we would
keep the records at certain friends
houses uh moving back and forth wow and
it's just because they were rated R that
was for music and that's because they
were punk rock and that was something
that would um that no one would
understand uh
um uh movies I know movies I wouldn't
even bring into the house that were
rated R
um but I would try to I would I would go
to the video store and this was this was
when I was married I go to the video
store and then I would like look around
to make sure no one from the
congregation was around and then I would
like you know and then I'd pick up oh
look at this rated G movie well this
looks very this looks very good yeah I
like this G movie can you put that in
there too because I want to know what
Martin scorsese's done and then um yeah
then I went to the library constantly
and um was just checking out every movie
that you know
stuff like I'd never seen apocalypse now
and it's just I never even I didn't know
what a war movie was I thought war movie
was just violence and terrible and it's
just like
oh no these are crafted films and so but
I would have to watch them on my own and
be very careful yeah
how do you define story and how do you
teach it to students and clients we tell
stories all the time even as I'm talking
to you I'm telling stories I'm bringing
characters in
um we
where we're made to tell stories we're
made to we're made to tell stories about
what you know our Aunt did that oh my
God she's she's crazy she's out of her
mind you know what she did and so we're
story building constantly just even even
if we don't know it and then that's when
we go okay so how do we craft it and
then it's just like let's that's when I
talk about character and plot let's talk
about a character
okay what does this character do let's
talk about plot and then um what I do
this
I do a free writing workshop for the
library once a month and so it's one of
my favorite things to do because I get
nobody I know in there it's just like
all of a sudden I have all these
eyeballs looking at me going teach us
how to write a story and and sometimes
they have a lot of experience and
sometimes it's the first time they've
ever even thought of being a writer and
um so right away I just talk about
character and plot and the what drives
me nuts about there's Monumental catalog
of books out there you know 500 pages
how to create a plot into screenplay 500
pages character work I throw all those
out there's not it we
can't be bogged down by this
intellectual this is how it is and Blake
blank blank blank blank it is good to
read those books I mean I'm a fan of
Joseph Campbell I'm a fan of
um
you know I I'm a geek about storytelling
but as far as as far as it's concerned
just start writing and just have a
character and just give them a goal and
then just get in the way of the goal and
just see what happens and then what I do
is I do free writing so I'll do a free
writing exercise so I'll just put that
I'll have them do a free write and then
they usually don't know that there's a
second and third part I'll throw in the
plot twist for them and and then they're
and then they they create kind of
full-fledged stories within 30 minutes
on the end there's a beauty to that it's
it's uh there's a beauty to
um
having a time limit
and then just going you know what
you all wrote crap everything you wrote
is problematic and awful I can't wait
till you bore me with your story because
what you wrote is you know you it took
you 30 minutes there's people that write
for years to write a good short story so
let's let's see what happens and
usually they're all very interesting
they're it's way more interesting than
anyone would ever think and um
so that's that's kind of how I wanted
you know I want people to just jump into
it and
write a story in 30 minutes and then
kind of walk away and go
I can do it and this is like yeah you
can but you kind of got to do it every
day
and it's got to be a practice like
anyone could anyone could do yoga they
might you know but you're not going to
go do a handstand on the first day if
you've never done yoga in your life you
got to come and practice every day you
gotta you know teach your body so when
you're writing you got to teach your
mind teach your mind that you're coming
to the page you're coming to the page
and your mind starts to go oh crap we're
coming to the page I better come up with
something so
yeah
can you give me an example of let's
suppose what a free writing sort of uh
assignment the in five minutes Karen I
need you to
and you you would have me write
something out what would it be so uh
what what I so here's an assignment that
I get that I give is I asked I I would
say Karen what what would be the
greatest job in the world that you could
ever have and think of anything
anything at all what would you like to
do for eight hours a day
and then I would hear what you would
like to do for eight hours a day and I'd
be like great on this scenario you're
going to get
50 million dollars a year to have this
job
but you only have one more you've been
through eight interviews they want you
you have one more interview
so you need to um you need to drive to
the interview but when you as you're
driving to the interview
you're gonna get a car accident and
someone's going to cut you off
and so right and I would tell you to
write that write that scene you got the
last interview for the greatest job in
the world for all the money you could
ever want but this car cut you off and
that would be the beginning of that
writing exercise
and then the plot twist that you know
everyone write it out and usually it's
just like that you know that just I'm
gonna cool and oh you know and it's just
great they like really get into it
because
they find something they're passionate
about the character right it's we've
created the character the character has
a passion and the character has a goal
and then
after that that limit I go okay great
now you're now your character's at the
interview
and they find out that the person they
got in the car accident with is the
person that's interviewing them
now how does that play out and that's
when it's just like you know because
they weren't thinking of that there and
so then they then they're like oh how do
we how do we resolve this huge problem
now usually that has been a very
contentious scene is now the person that
they need so
it's a lot of fun and then after that
um my big question is that the last
sentence is do they get the job or do
they not get the job and usually it's 50
50.
um so usually people find a way around
it people it's so that would be that
that would be one of the the one of the
one of the lessons I use a lot to get
someone to write and that would be about
30 minutes so I'd have them write about
10 minutes just really dive into the
anger of the scene 10 minutes of
resolution and then uh five minutes
after that so
excellent that sounds fun yeah I know
sometimes the beauty of being in a
writing class is just hearing the other
people it's not it's not so much getting
critique on your own yeah and in that
situation there's no critique at all
because it's just re it's just reading
it oh I see okay so and and for the most
part everyone is laughing at every story
because they're so good
and it's and people get really like I've
had people who are like that is the
first time I have ever read anything
I've written in front of everybody it
happens more than not and um you know
like were you expecting that reaction
they're like no and I'm like
you got story to tell so
make a decision you're going to join us
in hell
what is it laugh with the Sinners or cry
with the Saints um Virginia come on you
know yeah no I don't know why I'm
singing I shouldn't be singing why are
you allowing me to do this no no
but at Village I would join in if I knew
it I gotta watch Mystic Pizza I gotta
listen to Billy Joel if we were to have
a Tony Duchene five part writing process
to a story what would that be
I don't know why I'm drawing a blank a
pen paper okay uh yeah pen paper good
cup of coffee or whatever or whatever
drink
um and uh a desk or even a chair just
somewhere and
um
you know whether you're disturbed or not
Disturbed I think something that
happened with covid is uh people said oh
it must be great for you because you can
right now like you want I'm like no no
no you don't get it I have to be
irritated right people are not I need to
be in a cafe where people are talking
loud on their cell phones people are
being awful and I have to tune that out
and then I have to write I have to kind
of write in uh in situations where it's
kind of antagonistic where things are
coming at me and that's when I do my
best writing when I'm at peace I don't
do great writing
so
yeah yeah no the certain coffee shops
are great
um for conflict and for oh and it has to
be boring people are like oh do you have
intelligence yeah I'm like oh no I'm at
Coffee Bean
they're just like why would you go there
and like because it's boring and
corporate oh so you don't want too much
too much happening I don't want it to be
cool oh I see okay yeah yeah I I don't
want it to be hip okay so no filtered
water and you know
yeah erotica beans or what you've got to
have more just I mean my coffee bean has
great coffee so yeah you just want
something where it's not there's not
hipsters coming in all the time well no
it's it I just I don't want the whole
place to be a fashion show
you know hipsters are not I mean people
look at me and people look at me and
sometimes oh great there's a hipster
here I get it
well sometimes what's great are old
diners I know they're hard to find where
there's someone that I'll be right with
you and it's like they're gonna serve it
from one of those ancient coffee pots
and that's great because there's so many
characters in a place like that and it's
real quiet and there's just everyone you
know like each person has a fascinating
story like what they're doing and yeah
but there's not that many places like
that anymore they've been replaced
what writing failure has taught you the
most
it's funny I I my the first novel I
wrote
it's terrible
uh but I think
you have to write it to learn how to
write a novel it's like you have to
write a screenplay to learn how to write
a screenplay
um
so you just have to fail
uh
same time you kind of gotta as you come
to your first novel you know you have to
think oh it's going to be published it's
going to be great oh everyone's gonna
love it I'm a novelist just like
um and then you're just like you know a
year or two in and you're like
yeah I can't do anything with this
I got nothing
but you you've put in the time and you
kind of get the idea of what needs to be
done in order to you know
to write to write a novel so
did you think it was bad or did other
people say it uh no I thought it was bad
and I it was bad it was it was all over
the place
um
yeah I was
so what was it about uh it was uh it was
about a marriage that was breaking up
and uh yeah it's funny because it was
like night I wrote it like nine years
before my marriage broke up so maybe I
was just foretelling my future but uh
yeah it's you know
I was young and precious I think I think
if I'm precious with my work that's when
there's a problem I can't be precious
um
do you think you cared about the novel
too much I I think I cared about the the
the the label of me as a novelist too
much I think I was a little too hyped on
that
um
there's there's a beauty to there's a
beauty to um
what's interesting is once like once I
got published
and then your book comes out
there's a whole oh is that all there is
and that's you know that Peggy Lee song
is that all there is to book publishing
except it's different words but um
but it that's that's the greatest Club
to be in because
then you talk to other writers and
you're just like oh hey yeah how's your
book
uh you know when it's out and that's
that's usually the thing it's
it's uh
they could be or they could be excited
it's on the best seller list but they
got 12 interviews to do that day and
it's like so there's still that oh okay
I gotta get you know I I got to get in
this mindset of actually caring about a
book that I finished a year ago and um
you know it's uh it's bougie problems I
guess
do you think people feel the same once
their film comes out or that's different
um
the uh when when Jesus jerk came out
um so well I got to see the rough cut
and then when I when then when I saw it
at the first film festival it was at I
didn't I didn't know what the Final Cut
was going to be
so when I so when I was there
uh it was fun to watch but then I was
realizing that I was trying I was I was
gauging the audience I was I was
listening to the audience more than I
was watching the movie
um because I wanted to make sure the
jokes were landing and I wanted to make
sure that when there was supposed to be
silence there was silence
and um
so that's how that worked and then I saw
it one more time at another Festival
and uh and I did the same thing and I
was just like all right
what's what jokes what jokes are landing
what's working what's not working and it
was kind of consistent I was like
ah okay you know I'm just a screenwriter
I'm not the director but
when he you know he was there too and
then uh
and then after that I uh there was
another screening and I just stayed for
the First Act I was waiting for one
punch line
uh to see if the audience got it and
then they all got it and then I left and
uh came back later to do q a
um
I don't know if I've ever seen it again
in its entirety
and it's uh
it's a weird relationship because
I you know I see the film and I see
where I go oh I was right off camera to
the left oh that's the day that you know
that associate producer got in a fight
with the unit production manager oh you
know that's that's the day that I was
hiding behind the truck out of to make
sure I was out of frame but I can see
that it's so
uh my relationship to it is it's um
it's it's it's almost incestuous it's
almost too much to see
um
and it's uh you know very happy with it
but it's uh
it's a little disconcerting I guess so
again and I got to see it
in production so seeing it in production
is a very different experience and a
very lovely experience I think that was
my favorite part of the experience is to
see
the different takes and the different
choices the actors are making and
you know I'm looking at Eric and going
oh my God they're making me look good
and he'd be like they're making both of
us look good yeah so
yeah if the audience hadn't laughed at
that one punch line
what would have happened
I probably would have been we've totally
failed utter failure yeah
um those yeah I had definite punch lines
in mind
and a lot of them are lead actors Sasha
had to deliver and he did great and uh
yeah it's you know it worked so sure but
sometimes you know audiences don't you
we've all been in a film where we're the
only ones laughing and we're like why
are why am I the only one that's
laughing here yeah yeah that's on that
example I mean I and but at the same
time that movie was everything to me
because that movie was about me that
movie was my life
um and that book was my life so it was
the you know it was a
I wasn't sure if I should write it as a
memoir I mean I was writing it as a
novel to test it out as a novel and I
wasn't sure if I should pull out some of
the fictitious things to make it a
memoir when it was still in book form
but it read better as a novel to me and
it read better with more uh more
leniency into facts of the world up now
I I was a journal I was a journal I took
a journalistic approach to the world of
the Jehovah's Witnesses so I made sure
everything was absolutely factual
to the to the nth degree
across the board so I actually had to do
a lot of research on that but that movie
was that movie was Me growing that movie
was all me and so that movie was the
most that will be the most important
movie
probably of my career
because that's the story I needed to
tell and I needed to tell it that way
and not in the woe is me oh my God I
grew up in a restrictive religion no I
don't want I didn't want that I wanted
the levity of you know there's of the
okay and why people are there and I I
wanted I wanted more I didn't want a
definitive answer and um
to a lot of to a lot of uh you know
there's extra Jehovah's Witnesses out
there who do not like the movie because
I did because I portrayed the Jehovah's
I don't say anything bad about the
Jehovah's Witnesses and I'm like that's
on purpose because this is a just a
character study and it's essentially me
so
how does that character differ from
Johnny swade
yeah yeah yeah that's the fictional
character I should have clung on to
um
so uh the character's name's Gabe and uh
he's he's just Earnest he's trying to
just find his truth and he's trying to
live in it and he's trying to stay a
Jehovah's Witness
um and that's kind of what I did I was
trying to find my way to stay in
uh because I believed it through my soul
so but I also wanted to feel okay around
people who weren't Jehovah's Witnesses
and I also just wanted love
um so a lot of that is just the yearning
for um
for someone to be in love with
and you know me as a you know I know the
backstory of me because when I was six
years old I was engaged to Pamela
because I asked her to marry me and she
said yes you know I just I was very I
was very romantic
um and it just had this yearning for
family and that's how I saw my way out
of feeling bad of it's like oh when I
have a wife then I'll feel better as a
Jehovah's Witness and so uh you know the
Jesus jerk doesn't go that far into it
Jesus jerk is kind of ten years of my
life smashed into a
six months so
but Johnny Swede he
forgive me I'm gonna now I'm gonna go
watch the movie because now you have me
intrigued I want to see and you know who
doesn't want to see a Brad Pitt movie so
what would um what about that character
do you wish could have been you
um I don't know if I wish it could have
been me I think I just related to him
because he's kind of dumb but he's
earnest
so there's just like he's making
mistakes left and right and the you know
not that time in my life
it was pretty tumultuous because that
was around the same time that my friend
had died and I was um
I think I was just looking for something
and I think the character like Johnny
suede was trying to just fit into
something and he just he just wanted he
really just wanted a girlfriend
and
he was he just and he wasn't mature
enough to understand when
the right girl was right in front of him
that
it was right and uh and it just it yeah
so that all kind of made sense to me
what mistakes do writers make when
writing characters I don't know if they
make mistakes writing characters
um well maybe they do
um let's just find ways to make them
three-dimensional
um and there's always ways and I think
that's when I think in the end your
character just needs
we need to know what the character's
goal is and then just
make it harder for them that's that's
about it
um
so for the most part it's uh
yeah it's I I think I think I do find
some people are you know that then this
is one that comes oh no this is based on
a true story and no this is a real
person and it's just like okay but get
back to the get back to the page
stop doing the verbatim on you know but
I also think that's a technique that
technique that's a very great word for
it it's a way for people to avoid
actually writing it's a way for them to
avoid actually sinking into the conflict
of the possibilities of that character
so they can just say oh no this really
happened and it's just like you just
don't want to go there
that's okay
don't be a writer
it's not a it's it's not a hugely paying
gig unless it is sometimes it's it's
mostly sad
you know it's it only looks pretty in
movies so
why wouldn't what where would they not
want to go
I I mean I find this I find this a lot
and I find this in the majority of
you know maybe 70 of the students that
take my classes they they don't want to
they it's like when we were talking
about the um the evilness and the
Darkness I I don't think they want to go
into the darkness of their characters
because they're too scared to show the
darkness of themselves and that's when
we're gonna completely that's that's
just when the
the the the cat the sand castle of The
Story You're creating just won't work
it's
um you need to know the imperfections
that's that's the
the fun part you know
right so they make this character
too perfect or or it's too flat
yeah too flat and just it doesn't yeah
it's just it's reading like they're
avoiding
and usually I'll ask them what they're
avoiding and oh no no this really
happened and there's people there's a
lot of students who just don't want
notes and you just kind of find them and
go all right well you're not getting
notes then it's just like oh you know my
my standard is um oh well thanks for
sending this in and you know just
sprinkle more conflict
if a student's getting that note from me
that means that I realize they're not
taking any notes and they just want a
participation grade so
so if I let's suppose I turn something
in and and you you give me a first
passive first round of notes
and then you see that I don't integrate
or I don't change anything is that mean
I'm not receptive no it's um it usually
uh the you know I don't mind I don't
mind if a student's confused I don't
mind if a student is even offended like
whoa wait a second but the the con then
the conversation let's have the
conversation and um
and it doesn't mean that they need to
become take every note and become great
you know in the next scenes but but you
could start to tell
you know after a few workshops where
you're just like it just it just happens
there's the practice is happening it's
just like oh you're hitting it you're
hitting it you're hitting that conflict
you're you're hitting this I'm seeing
what you're doing and here and here and
here
um
you could just you could tell when
someone's avoiding
truth almost and when someone just uh
and that and that's that's the one thing
that I really kind of preach to every
writing class that I teach is
write your truth I can give you an
outline with 90 I can give you 90 story
Beats
with the character with the all the plot
and everything I can give it to every
one of you and tell you to go write it
and you're all going to come back with
completely different
um screenplays because you're going to
come with exactly who you are how you
grew up your tragedies your victories
you know it you you have the fingerprint
and that's the beauty of
being a writer it's like people get so
stuck on ideas oh that's a good idea
it's like it doesn't the idea doesn't
matter it's your fingerprint on how the
story how you're telling the story
because every story's been told you know
they may pretend like oh we got this new
thing that we did it like this and it's
just like all right but in the end it's
still a heist movie or in the end it's
still a love story uh that you know you
found a little different angle on but
they're the core of it the core that we
care about is still in there so that
then that will that'll never go away and
that's when I even say hey if you're
lucky enough to get on an Adam Sandler
movie and you know Adam Sandler's rates
Goofy movies but if you're lucky enough
to get a project on that put your truth
in there big go ahead and be goofy but
put an element of your truth in there
and that will make you stand above and
they'll be like I didn't when they read
it they'll be like you know what I don't
know why I like this but I like it and
that's when we're putting our own truth
into the work and we don't have to
totally spell it out but that's when
people go I connect to this and I don't
know exactly why or how but usually that
means the writer the writer has brought
in just utter truth and honesty and
storytelling
we find people are sometimes scared
because you're so honest
it intimidates them because then that
means they have to meet you at that
level
probably I should probably uh
be less intimidating
um well no not intentionally but but I
mean this is who you are and you want to
yeah and I don't expect I mean I I don't
expect everyone to have to you know deal
with uh the My Demons the way I deal
with them um yeah there's it's um you
know I I can tell when there's
uh avoidance in a Sci-Fi
you know it's the alien isn't looking at
themselves yeah yeah the alien looks at
himself in the mirror and says I'm
gorgeous and green yeah
um
there's there's just there's
it's just interesting because I think
and I didn't even realize this but I've
read so much work that I can really tell
fast
um if if they uh if they're into it and
if they you and if they had a stake in
writing it there's this with and I don't
know exactly what it is and I don't know
how to explain it but I could read five
pages of something and realize if um if
they're invested and this is important
or if this is an exercise and they're
trying to and they're just trying to
sell something
which could just be selling the teacher
for a good grade or yeah yeah okay or
even scripts that are given to me going
hey can you
you know can you do a read through on
this and give and give me uh some pages
of coverage and I'm like yeah and I'll
be like
sometimes I've given back scripts after
10 pages and I'll be like you didn't do
the work yet
um so and it's just you know and then
they're
uh there's something I have with um with
writing is I I kind of can't
I have a problem
sugar coating it sometimes but but
storytelling is my religion it's so it's
nothing I will ever
if there are gods of Storytelling I'm
never going to go against the gods of
Storytelling so I hate it when someone
asks me oh did you like my book and I'm
just like
you know
I I would never ask that of anybody I
don't even expect anyone to read
anything I you know but if someone says
that
um I kind of have to either tell them
the truth or avoid it in some way and
and sometimes I might might say you know
it was great to see you on that
publisher or I really like that you got
to work with that editor and all they
hear is great and like they don't hear
that I didn't say anything about the
book but I have to kind of
I can't say a book's greater a
screenplay is great
if I feel on my bones it's not
and I might be a jerk because of that I
don't know
also too sometimes if you're going on a
junket or press junket you don't always
have time to do I mean you sometimes get
this stuff last minute so you don't
always have time to read something or
even get a screener but but you know I
mean sometimes it's not just the work
it's also the person that did the work
and that's fascinating too
oh exactly oh I totally agree I agree
beyond belief there's I mean
that that the person behind the work
intrigues me I think I'm talking about
my friends when my friends come up to me
and we'll ask that and that throws me
off but like when I interview like every
once every like 15 to 20 people will ask
and um
that's uh I kind of have to I have to
restart I have to re-steer it because I
because when I do interviews I'm there
to have the conversation with the person
I'm not there to
uh if we discuss storytelling great if
you know but I'd rather
um I'd rather not go into the details of
the character of the book because that's
for other
you know that's for their other shows I
guess yeah or the question I love how
was it to work with so and so there was
such a big name you know is that's like
one of the I hear these journalists will
ask that in junkets and different things
and sometimes it's like well you're in
the sense insulting the person but hey
that's just my my thing is I always ask
were they not were they were they nice
to work with Okay
um and
it's really fun to hear because and then
you know I if I was uh yeah I was on uh
a set and right before covet and
someone's telling me about one of my
favorite stars and I was like how how
was he to work with um and they were
like
he was nice above the line but below the
line he was not a good person to people
and I was like ah
that's that's that you know I don't want
to hear that yeah and plus you don't
know what the person is going through
but I get it I guess if you hear enough
stories but sometimes you don't you know
there's a few people that I've heard
were difficult and then I've seen
someone come up and insist on a photo
and different things in a really rude
way and the person held it really well
and I was like wow they they actually
you know so you sometimes you just never
know you need to know the audience yeah
that's telling you that if it's someone
that's been working in film for 20 years
and they're working on film after film
after TV show after TV show I'll take
I'll take notice when they you know but
everyone knows everyone has a bad day
and sure sure I assume everyone has a
bad day so I never yeah if someone was
like oh I'm at someone on the street and
he was a jerk I just kind of look at him
and go I yeah I don't care
I was watching an old interview with
Jerry Seinfeld I think it was with
Charlie Rose and he said something to
the effect of he knew when it was right
to eventually leave the show and to stop
being a part of it and he said if I
leave now meaning stop the show the
audience will have this thing where they
will never have to say it was good and
then it started to run out of gas how
does a writer know for their project or
their scene even
that okay I think I should stop now
because if I keep going then
they're going to be like yeah this this
kind of ran out of gas for me
yeah that's interesting I I mean I I
call it keeping everyone in the room as
long as possible uh and I know and uh
and just because we're always trying to
avoid conflict as humans it's hard to
sometimes it's even harder to keep our
characters in scene when the conflict is
just rocking
um and let it let it play out and then
so I think what I think it's more
important to let it play out and then
get them out to the next scene of okay
that happened and since that happened
now this is going to happen and how are
they going to get out of that situation
um
so yeah I think that's I feel like
that's that's for scene work but if you
know if I was Seinfeld I would have
taken the money and said what five
million an episode let's go 10 more
seasons
um you know but I'm not but he's a
stand-up comedian he's not a he's not a
you know at heart so like kind of like
like I get that I'm a novelist of the
heart so I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
kill the novelist in me to make a TV
show work uh he's not gonna kill the
comedian and him to make a next season I
guess
sure but in the reverse you you had a
screenplay that you were working on
during this lockdown and you wanted to
extend it and do it in novel form so
there's been a reverse too where you
realize it sounds like you weren't done
telling the story
and you wanted to tell more
yeah I don't know if it yeah I it just
it doesn't feel finished
and I think
it's it was just it's it's weird but it
was like speaking to me too much it just
kept speaking to me and I just I kept
seeing it so
um this is how it's showing itself to me
I guess
um which is uh
very you know I I really don't work in
the most efficient means I should have
Rewritten the screenplay and started
pushing it around and trying to you know
make it happen but
um that you know it's I don't know why
I feel like I had to re I have to kind
of re-enter it
um maybe because I that I was doing it
as I thought oh yeah this would be a fun
story and it started as a fun story then
it meant something to me and I guess
when it meant when it means something to
me that's when it kind of like
oh this actually I do need to tell this
this is this is something that
this is something that's personal to me
that I need to tell
and that's when um that's when
I feel like
um I'm only part of the process and I
have to
I have to do justice to this thing
um I I have to step up and be the very
best I can be to what needs to be told
with these characters and so
what um what you know I'll in in heavy
rewrites I'll really know what needs to
stay and What needs to go but
I I you know I I do know the story and I
knew I know where everything goes I just
this is when I'm just just for some odd
reason I'm sinking deeper and deeper and
it who knows maybe it's maybe it's just
a book and never becomes a screenplay
and that just everyone laughs at me to
the end and they say well you're in
development and I go I know what that
means I'm going to it's going nowhere
development hell that's what it means
what's the definition of that oh that's
uh well the the uh oh your your book's
option oh my God oh my God who's
interested Antonio Banderas he's
interested oh my God and it's just like
you know like four four four there was a
four people who called each other and
then Antonio Bandera said oh interesting
and then interesting became like he's
interested and he's interested became
like he's clearing his schedule and he's
clearing his schedule became
um he wants to talk to you but not yet
so kind of like a waiting for guffman
type of thing okay right yeah yeah and
then it becomes a game of telephone but
you just don't believe anything you just
you just smile and say thank you yes and
then it's it's a miracle anything gets
made so if someone's in that situation
what's your advice to them
in the situation of getting optioned
yeah just enjoy it I mean it's it's
actually it's actually a nice ego boost
to have you know maybe someone talked
about you it's like it's nice in a good
way yeah maybe it's it's an ego boost
like oh maybe someone read your book
it's just like oh that's sweet I don't
it's not even a relative that's nice so
it's um
yeah I just I just
you know there's development hell but
there's also just that kind of a
gratitude of well some people seem to
care a little bit and
you know if it goes further great and if
it doesn't be working on someone
something else that's
um it's a story you need to tell so
yeah that's what I was wondering so
especially for someone that maybe is
outside of the industry they're in
another state or country and their work
is being optioned
so they're not waiting by the phone like
a like someone waiting for their date to
call who you know like alone you know on
a Saturday night oh Tommy's supposed to
call and Tommy doesn't call so what else
should you be doing you should be
writing something new writing something
new being with being with your people
and your writers and your writer friends
who can keep you in check you know it's
uh
yeah I I've done everything wrong it's
uh I went to my 20-year High School
reunion and I um that's before Jesus
jerk was uh that's right when I finished
my final draft of Jesus jerk before I
started submitting to agents and at the
reunion I was like I'm a novelist I'm a
novelist it's just like and I it was I
was the epitome of the stupid guy
because I wasn't I wrote a novel but no
one may ever see the light of the day
fortunately I finally found an agent and
a publisher but it was sheer ignorance
on my part to say I'm a novelist before
I have a book published before I have an
agent uh just because I have a draft
done and it could have been the
oh remember remember that guy Tony we
went to high school with we ran around
the the uh the the you know everyone
telling you everyone he was a novelist I
saw him scooping ice cream the other day
you know it's and uh not that there's
anything wrong with that because
probably most novelists need to do
published all of us need to do that
anyway but um
I've just learned to uh
to to be a little more realistic with
myself uh and also like kind of
I guess I guess I had a lot of Joy at
the time and plus with that scenario
being able to write a novel after coming
out of the Jehovah's Witnesses and doing
something that was so
utterly not not frown not just frowned
upon to to be creative and that's that
was my whole kind of life was just
crushing my creativity
um so to be able it was almost like I I
come out and go I'm a creative person so
yeah I was Johnny swade I was that was
that was kind of the buffoon
um and I'm I'm gonna write a book on
like one of these days I'll write a book
or an article on everything I've done
wrong in publishing in the film industry
so you don't have to it's just
it it'll be probably the largest book
I've written but you went to that that
high school reunion feeling good and you
left feeling good yeah no one tried to
burst your bubble no that's good uh well
and I also found out that they all knew
I was a Jehovah's Witness I was trying
to hide it at school you know I'd be
like I said I would uh I would wear
suits to school you know and like I
found out that this yeah I found the
specials record the first specials
record and they were mod and they all
wore suits and I'm like I just got to
look like that so if I'm looking like
that at school and then I'm walking
around with my Bibles and watch Towers
on Saturdays maybe they'll just think
I'm just walking around so I didn't I
thought I was kind of fooling everyone
at school
um but it turned out they were like oh
no we knew you're a Jehovah's Witness
but we always thought you were cool and
I was like hmm there's a lot of
Revelations to me that night interesting
and do you still keep in touch with any
of those people I do yeah yes yeah
yeah okay and so now they see that not
only did you publish your book but then
you also made the film maybe uh they
probably don't even care right they get
to see that they're you know I get
photos of their grandkids oh no you know
or I'll find out uh you know one one is
a doctor and I mean he talked to me
about vaccination stuff and what is you
know going on there and it's just like
yeah
in the end
um they might not be readers and they
might not be viewers and that's that's
the beauty of it it doesn't matter I
always come into it now with going you
know I
now I'm just like I assume no one's read
anything or seen anything I've ever done
and if they have then I'm pleasantly
surprised and I say thank you that's uh
oh it's people will apologize oh my God
I haven't watched your film yet I'm like
you don't have to don't worry about it
there's other things in life going on
you know there's so and it's on IMDb you
can you can watch it uh it's like I on
Amazon IMDb they have a
yeah yeah it's on Amazon it's on Prime
and um yeah I don't know I haven't I I
think it's like someone said it was on
YouTube for free so I guess the
distributor put it on there for free
which
I have no I have no uh
what do you call it I have no Authority
on that on that end of it I just so yeah
it's out there people can watch it sure
yeah and there's the DVD too I I I have
the DVD I haven't even opened the
wrapper yet it's just like oh okay it's
uh yeah it's like the bottle of
champagne you just want to put you don't
want to you want to open it to uh I
don't even know where it's at in my
house I was when uh when the Giants went
to the World Series and Tim in like 2010
and 10 minutes to come got like three Cy
Young Awards and they asked him where he
put him and he said he thinks they're in
the they he thinks that they're in his
car and I thought that was just so like
dumb at the time and then now it's like
Oh no I got that yeah it's because it's
about the work it's not about the
it's not about the end it's about the
it's about the middle
would you say filmmakers today are more
concerned with forcing a message than
telling a good story
I see it yeah I see it a lot
um
and I I think
I think people are concerned
about
how they're portrayed instead of the
what the story is talking about
and um
which is the you know people do what
they need to do that's not how I work
um I have no problem eating crow if I
have to uh as long as I'm telling the
story is um
it's truthfully and from the heart as
possible but
um yeah I mean I I I see it a lot where
people are people are trying to steer
their stories in a marketing way it's
like oh this is fresh and they're like
well I'm writing fresh and I said never
ever do that because
it just it reeks of um
and authenticity but you know what
there's
80 percent in in authentic films out
there that are making a ton of money so
I I'm not right on that
um it's like very successful careers are
being made uh it's just not how I do it
so it's uh
it's it's not how I approach it and it's
not
how I want to consume it I don't want um
I I know I I preached door to door
knocking on doors with the word of
Jehovah for 20 years of my life
um the last thing I ever want to do is
preach even if I believe in something I
don't want my belief system to
um
to find its way into the story and push
it on the viewer I always want the
viewer or the reader
to have their own questions and come up
with and go oh that's interesting I'm
not sure if that uh blank I'm not sure
if blank I don't I don't want them to
know
the most beautiful compliment I got when
Confessions of a Teenage Jesus jerk came
out the film was
um they people thought I was still the
Jehovah's Witness
and I was just like yeah I did it right
uh because yeah I I do not believe in
that belief system at all it's very
corrupt and it's
it's not good
um but what I'm telling the story my
message can't be in there I could tell I
could tell the world of
but I love it that people aren't sure
if I'm still affiliated with the
religion or not that's the greatest
compliment and I feel like that should
be
I would love that to be across the board
where if someone I don't want to know
their political affiliation I don't want
to know I don't want the film or the
story to tell me
where they are I want I want them to
explore the Human Condition because
that's what we all got so
he said something to the effect of 80
percent of movies nowadays
do seem to fall into a category of a
message they're doing quite well who do
you think the audience is
for those films
um I mean it's it's interesting because
I don't I don't think the audience this
is why Hollywood
is a weird business because I don't
think the audience is too critical of
certain things because the general
audience is there just to be entertained
what are we doing on Saturday night
honey we're going to the cinema Cineplex
well who's what's there I don't know but
that cute guy in that films in this film
well great let's go and they go and then
they enjoy it and then they go home
they're they're and their enjoyment of
it is great well great it's that's
that's what it's for what
um even if it has a message what a great
gift that those filmmakers gave to those
people who got to go on a date and then
got to go home and cuddle and just you
know come together because they saw a
movie that I wouldn't necessarily care
to see so
the viewership is just so vast that I
you know I I don't want him to make a
judgment on those people
um I just I'm just uh
you know I and those people do not want
to see my movie I mean and they've been
vocal about it on the internet so it's
just like you know I turned that off
after five minutes because what this
this and this and I'm like
you know
yeah it's not for you that's fine I
because I don't write for everybody I
never want to write for everybody I I
want the I want people
to not like me and I'll feel like I'm
doing a I want people to like me of
course but I do want a certain
population to not like what I'm doing
because then it then I know I'm um
then I know I'm hitting the authenticity
and I'm hitting the truth and
there's and you know and sometimes I
disgust myself I was you know I'm just
like it's probably it's probably why I
can't read my old work or you know watch
old stuff is it's just too much because
it's just too much uh
not that it's bad not that I don't not
that I don't think it's good it's just
it's too much to consume
on my own as like a reader or a writer
or as a viewer it's uh
it's it's weird yeah
you know like familiarity breeds
contempt so you're you're too much of
yourself you know how we all see
ourselves in a different light not not
contempt I think it's just um
that was a point in time and and that's
and that's all that and that's what it
was and how lucky am I
but I'd rather watch a new episode of
money Heist on Netflix
um you know it's uh
yeah I don't know I I don't even know
why I said that I have therapy at 10 A.M
tomorrow I can talk to
my therapist about it okay no I mean I
get it I mean some people after a while
they're like okay I'm glad I've passed
this phase I don't want to live here
anymore in this like mindset so I I can
understand that yeah it's yeah yeah
with so many remakes and reboots being
made today how can creators truly tell
Original Stories
well yeah I don't I I get the franchise
thing you know oh Aquaman worked and
people know what Aquaman is
um a Whopper Works they're gonna go buy
a Whopper instead of the hamburger at
the local mom pod joint because they
don't know what that is
um I I think I don't think there's a lot
of originality in the stories there's
originality in how they're told and
the originality of how we're bringing
our unique
um voice
and uh to what a story that's already
been told over and over again and then
we get and then we get together with uh
the actors who have their own unique
ways of working and then the directors
have their unique ways of working and
that's where the beauty comes or that's
where it totally flops and dies
but um
yeah I mean for the reboots you know
they got to make reboots so they can
give money to the stuff that maybe
someone cares about I guess
and actors even got to do it too I don't
think any of these actors that work in
superhero movies I I don't think they
really want to but that paycheck's
really good and it's just like I'm gonna
get and that cost him again and you know
it's and I would get in the costume too
because
who wouldn't want to buy a house in Los
Feliz sure the Palisades all right
private schools and yeah exactly it's
it's great decision making so
um yeah I don't think I'm getting hired
on any of those as a writer uh but me
you know maybe maybe they want someone
contrarian to come in so sure have you
seen any remakes that were actually
better than the originals well Ocean's
11 for sure
way better than the train wreck that was
the Frank Sinatra
uh doing a rat pack Ocean's Eleven
um let me try to think of uh
summer rates some remakes that were
better than the originals I don't know
it does happen sometimes
um
I I think uh it's a it's a there's a
there's a narrative where they try to
take great films from the past and
remake them now I think they should go
for the crappy films in the past and
remake them I would love to see remakes
of terrible films like what I I don't
know uh maybe a hard R version a Parent
Trap no I
I don't know why was Oceans 11 why was
the first one so horrible
I well I've only seen it once I don't
know if have you seen it not not the you
said the one with Frank Sinatra yeah
yeah yeah the rap packs are yeah it's
um they didn't care I don't think there
was any care taken in it it's like we
got these Stars let's put them together
uh when it got to uh sodenberg
seems like there was caretaken uh and
you can tell there's um
where there's it's
you know it's a blockbuster film but you
look at the frame by frame and you and
you look at the decisions that were made
and it's just like
every decision is a great decision this
is you know it's uh the the and there's
a lot of little elements in there too I
can't remember who wrote the screenplay
but
the the beautiful little elements and
little choices that are made that's it's
it's it's it's what
just brings it all together yeah what
classic film it would be a travesty they
tried to remake it today it would just
be insulting
oh I don't know
I don't know I think everything should
be given a try I mean the Gus fans Aunt
did a try on psycho which was just awful
it's like Vince Vaughn was
um yeah I know it's no one remembers it
there's a reason it's because it was
terrible and I think they use the exact
same script you know and uh it was yeah
but
give it a try why not I mean hey people
you know it's if someone's gonna hey
I'll write a remake of something I'll
I'll write a remake of a great movie
and hope I can do better and then
everyone can just dirt on it and you
know I yeah it's
I I say have fun with it I say I say
ruin great films
why ruin them well I mean if you're
gonna remake them
yes it's it's it's a canvas it's like
it's it's a you know why why not go
ahead and try to resketch it and and I
hate this word intellectual property but
it's all about oh we have this property
let's renew this property and let's make
money on it and I understand the
business sense of it so
um not that I'm gonna run out and be
excited that they remake A you know a
certain film like you know The Bicycle
Thief or whatever is you know I was like
let's remake it modern day Los Angeles
um you know what go ahead actually
um it's yeah it's uh there's so there's
so much crap being made it doesn't
matter if more crap's made I guess I'm
okay yeah what if I take music though
which I know is near and dear to your
heart as well some some you know like
you said uh was it on camera or off
camera the Public Image Limited was one
of your first concerts that you went to
okay so pil what if there was a a band
that was trying to remake all those
songs and there was a Johnny Rotten that
was the new the new guy it wasn't Johnny
Rotten but it was like this new
influencer guy they kind of looked like
Johnny Rotten and had sort of the same
Sensibility
Justin Timberlake can remake it I'll be
like oh let's see if it's good okay yeah
I I guess I guess I'm not nostalgic
about it
um I've already had my experience with
uh the the either the original film or
seeing the original band and um
yeah so
um
I I don't I I'm I'm realizing now that
I'm not really nostalgic if somebody
tries to remake something I'm like go
ahead and do it they can remake Jesus
jerk and make it a uh you know make it a
superhero film and
but you know just send me the check okay
why do you think people though are so
precious
about some of these films or adaptations
of certain books well like why are why
are some people so adamant that it
shouldn't be done that it
you know because they're all fans that
would that are that are angry that the
original work
yeah I guess they attribute meaning to
it and meaning to it in their own lives
um but it's
I I don't know if they uh if they work
in film or if they are writers uh they
could be uh
you know and and the writing you know
and film is it's meant to be critiqued
it's meant to be just ripped apart
that's what everyone's supposed to do
that's
the that's the beauty of of all of it
it's you're having a conversation about
it great it's it create it's continuing
the conversation so
um
yeah I mean it's you know it's um
who there was like what was that rock
and rock and roll High School The
Ramones were in rock and roll high
school then they had rock and roll High
School too Corey Feldman was the it was
the band of rock and roll High School
too and um
you know people hate it but I get a kick
out of it I'm like there's Corey Feldman
pretending like he's Michael Jackson
it's just like it uh
I'm not upset about it uh because
there's the first one that meant a lot
to me as a kid and uh the second one is
Corey Feldman pretending like he's
Michael Jackson
sure and the Ramones were at the height
of their stardom when that came out I
you know I think they gained more
stardom I think after that movie came
out I think that's yeah I think they I
don't think they realized that was going
to put them to a new level
but I don't know I can't remember
because I can't remember exactly when
the movie came out
why I saw it on VHS oh nice